one
um
oh
[Music]
[Music]
wow
as long as there's
yes
okay
[Music]
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
right
[Music]
okay
[Music]
six six five two nine appearances on the
record please starting with the
prosecuting attorney
we have other people thank you john mark
peace out people
good morning i'm shannon smith on behalf
of jennifer crumley for the purpose of
the exam and today i am going to
represent miss crumley
and my partner is going to represent mr
crumbly so that we can keep our
arguments clean and separate
good morning marielle layman on behalf
of james crumbly
so just for clarification the in terms
of any uh cross-examination and direct
examination ms smith you will be taking
cross-examination and direct examination
for miss crumbly only and ms lima will
be doing it for mr
we have discussed
a potential conflict every period i do
believe that is appropriate for
defendants both defense counsel to
acknowledge a potential conflict to
place that way
yes um i have made the record of that on
each appearance i'm planning on doing it
today as well
again um as uh both of you have been
aware and i made both of you aware of
the fact there's potential for a
conflict of interest in this case due to
the fact that your attorneys are
representing you and they are attorneys
and counsel in the same firm
but ms crumley do you understand any
potential conflict that might exist with
both of these attorneys representing
both you and your husband
and mr crumbling yes miss crumbly
knowing that potential conflict are you
willing to waive any conflict that may
exist and proceed today with ms smith um
representing you here for purposes of
the preliminary examination yes mr
crumbly what about you do you uh are you
willing to waive any potential conflicts
that exist with having missed lehman
representing you knowing that
ms smith is representing your wife yes
yes
all right um before we move forward
we've got a couple of um
motions that were filed for the record
today is the daytime suffer the
preliminary examination in this case
um the attorneys have had the
opportunity to meet with each other
um regarding some of the exhibits is
there still the necessity to address
that motion
oh motion to adjourn your honor the
motion to adjourn in the basis for the
reason for the adjourn yes there is
and uh miss layman is going to argue
that motion
good morning your honor
the defense did file a motion um for a
more compressed witness list and to
adjourn
um we have reviewed the discovery that
we received from the prosecution at the
time your aunt may remove my ass
take as long as i've ever been
comfortable thank you
at the time of filing our motion there
were a number of materials that we had
not received from the prosecution since
filing the motion the prosecution has
elected to provide additional discovery
to us on february 1st february 2nd
february 3rd and february 4.
um we did again ask the prosecution to
provide us with a more
specific witness list the original
witness list that was provided was
approximately 30 witnesses we asked for
a shorter witness list so the
prosecution provided us with a list of
16 witnesses
we did ask them for more specifics
regarding their witnesses so that we
could better focus our attention on
preparing with our clients and also
preparing ourselves for the preliminary
examination today in reviewing the
materials that were provided on february
i believe second and february 4th we
learned that there were some materials
that had not been provided by the
prosecution to us specifically in
regarding one of the witnesses that they
expect to take the longest today and
that's detective wagrowski
um we have met with the prosecution the
prosecution indicates that it sounds
that they do have the materials that
have not been provided to us but they
have not provided them um
it's been
your honor we have not been able to
review their reports specifically
created by the detective
video specifically created by the
detective
it's our understanding that those
reports may or may not be used today but
that doesn't mean that they don't
contain information that could be
relevant to the defense
in your honor in the amount of discovery
that has been provided to
us by the prosecution so far there are
at least 67 hours of recordings
as we've made the court aware in order
to have in-person visits with our
clients we have to obtain a court order
for each visit we have to obtain a
negative pcr covid test at least 72
hours before the visit or i'm sorry no
more than 72 hours before the visit and
we have to schedule the in-person visit
with our clients
um we did have we were able to
successfully schedule two visits with
our clients last week
um
however
we have not been able to review all of
the
recorded discovery even all of the
recorded discoveries specific to some of
the witnesses today because there was
other there were other materials and
matters that we needed to discuss um if
we do want to visit with our clients
your honor as i'm sure the court is
aware if we don't do it in person it's
done through a software which quite
frankly your honor has failed us more
times than it hasn't um and we're also
limited in time on those visits we're
limited to half an hour at a time and we
can't schedule multiple visits
back-to-back
um so your honor it's it's obviously
been very difficult to prepare for this
examination with the amount of discovery
that the prosecution has provided
um and the amount that the prosecution
has provided that's relevant to our
clients is also buried within the amount
of discovery that they've provided to us
um so your honor is even though we've
taken a number of steps to
effectively prepare for our preliminary
exam today we do still have concerns
that
that there are things that we are
missing um we just had a conversation
about text messages that we haven't seen
your honor so
the prosecution has indicated that they
may have an explanation for why we
haven't seen them but we do still have
concerns judge and
today even the prosecution indicated
that their list is even shorter than the
16 that they provided to us as recently
as last friday so judge
the the police reports that we've
reviewed indicate that there are dates
with which pro law enforcement has
provided
over a hundred gigabytes of data to the
probably over 200 gigabytes of data to
the prosecutor's office and we've
received that data
sometimes weeks later so judge we do
have concerns about the material that's
been provided to us we do have concerns
that we're missing material that will be
relevant to the preliminary examination
and we we can't be effective without
being able to review everything judge so
we are asking that the court adjourned
the preliminary examination for these
reasons
response thank you judge we just spent
45 minutes with defense counseling
that everything in this binder that we
put together
has been turned over now just a few
minutes ago this smith approached me and
said there's a text thread that she
didn't think she had or may have been
deleted
our expert in computer crimes is going
to testify regarding how a user may or
may not believe things and how it would
be exported from a celebrate system
that's not new information josh we have
turned over everything in an
unprecedented fashion by way of example
when we receive the search warrant
returns
from social media
such as instagram and facebook on
february the 1st our paralegal who's
been dedicated to this case since
november the 30th every day she has
worked on just this case she's gathering
discovery she's compiling it she's
cataloging it she's redacting it when
necessary she turned that around in one
day so the statement that this is some
sort of strategy quite frankly judges
just misses the marketplace
we are following the rules we're
following the court rules we're found
all the rules of discovery we are ready
to proceed today
the information that council just
referenced regarding detective
that's something called call detail
records we've already indicated we're
not going to admit that the exam and
those call detail records have been
turned over to defense
now judge we have to turn over
everything that we possibly could have
to proceed today and like i said the
prosecution has been following all the
sports members thank you
all right the defendants did file an
emergency motion to compel witnessless
door and the alternative to adjourn the
preliminary examination on february 2nd
2022. the quarters had the opportunity
to review the motion the response
also did have a discussion with both
attorneys relative to the nature of the
discovery that had been turned over and
what had not been turned over and or
they believed had nothing turned over
the court did allow both
all attorneys to meet prior to beginning
today's hearing for approximately 45
minutes to go over all that discovery in
addition the court adjourned this
preliminary examination for
approximately six weeks because it did
acknowledge and understand that the
discovery in this case would most likely
be voluminous
having taken all those measures the
court finds that there's sufficient
evidence that has been turned over to
the defense attorneys at this point in
time that their good cause does not
exist to adjourn the exam again and
there is a good likelihood that this
exam will not
complete today and then it may need to
go into another dating time so having
taken all those factors into
consideration the court is going to deny
the motion
um do you think your prosecutor also had
notion
judge the people motioned well for
strict communications between the
defendants to report it became known to
us that during uh certain zoom breakdown
productions the defendants were making
certain gestures to each other
we're asking support for this court's
inherent authority to restrict the
communication judge i didn't follow
clean i believe it speaks for itself
yes um your honor the fact that the
prosecution wasn't even aware of the
communications until they were later
told by other people
shows that our clients weren't trying to
do anything to disrupt all of the
communication they didn't realize it was
being broadcasted
um they certainly didn't intend to hurt
any of the victims from oxford um
on that we apologize to the court i
already told the prosecution i would
tell our clients not to have
communications at the table or send
messages if i love you at the table they
agreed there was no reason to file the
motion our clients are will behave
they're not they're not going to do
anything like that and they certainly
don't need to offend anyone thank you
the court has had the opportunity to
review and consider the motion that was
filed by the prosecutor as well as the
oral arguments
i'm going to break the motion as it
relates to import proceedings mr mrs
probably this is a court proceeding um
during the course of any breaks or while
maybe i'm looking away or somebody else
is looking away you're not to have
communication with each other it's
disruptive and it is disrespectful okay
all right are we ready to begin
may i address the complications for one
reason
one additional factor i don't believe
it's ever been placed on the record by
the defense that they understand that
they're not they're not similarly
situated they have the same charges but
the evidence will be different against
one that is against the other i think
it's important to note it's important
for the defendants to understand that
you may have accomplished that regard
any response from the defense counsel
your honor we acknowledge that the cases
are different for mr crumley versus mrs
crumbly and it's part of the reason to
make it easy for this court i'm going to
represent jennifer crumbly and miss
layman is going to represent james for
the purpose throughout this hearing um
i
i don't think this is a concern the
prosecution needs to be raising we're
very aware of the
at least evidence that we believe will
be and i'll just confirm with the
defendants again mr miss is probably
starting with mrs crumley do you
understand that there's potential that
you have different interests and you are
not necessarily on an even
even par with each other in terms of
what your issues may be which again
could lead to a potential conflict of
interest do you understand that yeah and
knowing that do you still want to
proceed today with these attorneys yes
mr pumbley do you understand that yes do
you still want to proceed today with
these attorneys yes you can go ahead and
go ahead and call your first question
i'm sorry we do have two very quick
preliminary veterans first we'd ask the
court to um
have a sequestration order
and make that even more explicit only
because there are witnesses who can view
the court proceedings from outside of
the courtroom with the live streaming so
we would ask that every witness be
instructed there not to view the other
witnesses and through sequestration
okay that's the point with the day of
fault
i believe
um i the witnesses are to my knowledge
all the witnesses have been sequestered
the only witnesses that might be in the
courtroom is the first witness is that
correct
i'm going to take a minute and have the
um the prosecutor or the deputy advise
the other witnesses that they are not to
view
anything on their phones their phone
should be off um
policy from the supreme court is that if
they're in the common areas of the
courthouse they can have their phones
they can have them on in the courtroom
you cannot
so i am going to direct that they turn
their phones off
until after they leave the courthouse
and then your enter just another issue
which has doesn't have anything to do
with prosecution um in light of some of
the new information that we've been
given this morning myself and my
co-counsel need to
communicate with our clients by writing
notes my client cannot write with the
belly chains can she please have a hand
free and mr crumbly have a hands-free so
that they can write back and forth to us
it will allow us to be able to
communicate with them without having to
disrupt their proceedings and staff them
um because we we did receive some
different information than what we've
received uh prior to today's hearing i
i've been deferred to the sheriff's
department
yeah your honor due to their their
status i don't feel comfortable in
moving their hands
i'm sorry
because of their status their maximum
security status i don't feel comfortable
removing the costs
the problem is
i'm just trying to figure out how we can
uh
she hold the
the
pad on her lap
and i will give you a moment in between
if you need to confer with them okay
all right we it might take us
several moments as we go through the
exhibit yeah so you just have everything
on your keep the legal pad on your lab
um and
you can i know i don't have any any
anything that the table doesn't go over
so it doesn't give you an opportunity to
kind of slide underneath there your
honor is it possible and i guess this
would be a question for the deputies is
it possible just to handcuff them
without the belly change that way
they're still cuffed
no that wouldn't be possibly your honor
they need to remain in their what
they're brought in
i'm sorry i can't hear you they need to
remain in what they're about yes
okay
all right uh
first witness
uh the prosecution called secure penance
i'm just going to go over a couple of
things with you real quickly
um you can have it scoot up as close to
those microphones as you can
if at any time
you are so comfortable enough and you're
wanting to remove your mask you can do
so um i also am going to ask you to keep
your voice up so that we can all hear
you
and speak clearly and
make sure you are verbalizing all
responses don't shake your head or say
aha
okay
okay can you please state your full name
for the record and spell both your first
and last name
my name is
[Music]
do you own the farm
i do okay can you tell the judge what
that entails
um we have some mortgage horses so
people pay us to take care of their
horses
um
we
need horses to water them we turn them
outside
and then we also offer training services
where we
put training on horses or give
riders lessons so how does the business
um
the
boarding
side of the business covers you know the
expenses of
you know the feed in water the
necessities for the horses and then um
it also covers the care so we have some
workers that
help to
keep business going because eli horses
okay without giving the specific address
what town or township or city is what is
the farm located
and karen do you know um
jennifer and jamie
i do do you see them in the courtroom
here today yes could you point to
jennifer probably or tell me what
something she's wearing
she is right here in the front she is
wearing a mask and glasses okay
notice that the witness is identified
i met her a few years ago um and i met
her through the horse world she
had a horse at the time sorry when you
say a few years ago we need to know if
all possible what
what what year was that
i do not recall the exact year was it
more than three years ago
i do not believe so okay when you met
her uh did you own your business at the
time no i did not so how did you meet
her
um i have some friends that uh were
familiar with the barn that she had her
horse going to okay at the time that she
had one horse or two one and what was
the name of the horse shorty okay
and
currently how many um horses did the
crumbles or do the company's um
they have two okay and at some point
another horse was purchased
um yes the second horse was purchased
earlier in 21.
okay and what's the second horse's name
billy and do you know how that purchase
was made and in what circumstance
um
that was an online purchase she had the
horse shipped to michigan and did she
tell you why or how that happened um she
was looking for a new horse that she
could do some jumping on um as shorty
had an injury where he could not be
jumping
so she happened to find this horse
online and uh she purchased that
did she leave you here did she tell you
um how that occurred
um
she
was drinking that night and i said that
she
made a purchase okay how do you know she
was wrong uh she even told me
what exactly did she say did she say she
was intoxicated or she country she said
that she was directly okay and did she
tell you how much the horse cost
she said the horse cost five thousand
dollars all right and you're telling
your testimony is that happened in 2021
yes of what month
was it after you owned the business
no this was at a different boarding
facility okay so do you know about what
month it was purchased
um the horse ended up showing up in
february okay um i'm not sure exactly
when the actual purchase after fell okay
at some point both of the horses were
boarded with you right yes and when did
that occur
um both horses ended up becoming boarded
with me in
june
to the july time period of 21. okay and
can you tell me what services
if any have you offered james and
jennifer probably with regard to your
business
um we have boarded their horses so we
take care of them and then um we were
also giving lessons to both of them and
turning training on their horses okay so
how much per horse does it cost to board
and feed
per month
um
the board price for the pasture board
that they were on is um four hundred
dollars a month four hundred dollars per
month per horse yes okay and then in
addition you said that you were giving
lessons
yes believing lessons too
i was giving lessons to both jennifer
and james um but then ended up
more so just giving lessons to
jennifer as i don't specialize in the
western
writing okay and your testimony is you
opened your business in june so what how
many lessons approximately per week was
the goal for jennifer
the goal was about three lessons a week
um how long are those lessons
about 45 minutes to an hour and how much
do they cost they cost 35.
okay
and then did james also have lessons
every week
no he did not take lessons every single
week but he would take us
okay
about how much time
let's just narrow it down from june
until
november
um how many days a week would you see
the prom face
i would say they would be out there
about three to four days a week three to
four days a week just during the week or
on the weekend as well
both week and weekends um
usually i would only for them one day on
the weekend
and for about
when they came
to the bar what did they do and how long
did it take
they would groom their horses and tack
them up and ride them
um and then cool them down and uh put
them away
um and that usually took about three
hours
okay did did either one of them have
jobs at that time
yes
do you know what they did
i do not know
exactly what job they have do you know
what their hours are
i do not what about what time did they
arrive in
during the day
they would usually come around five
o'clock on the weekdays and then
weekends they
would usually come around like between
nine and eleven in the morning
did they for the most part come together
yes okay
did their son ever come for them
i have not seen their son at my barn
okay and that would be since june
yes uh have you ever seen him
i have seen him maybe once or twice
and that would be it the previous one
yes okay
so you're saying so
three to four times a week
probably around five o'clock about three
hours yes okay
did the horses ever require any
care
other than just boarding and feeding and
grooming
um yes sometimes we've had to put um
like ointments or take care of them if
they injure themselves or need some type
of fat care
okay um along with uh holding them for
the barrier okay
for those of us in the world that aren't
exactly sure what a barrier is can you
tell the court what that is
basically a person that does a pedicure
for horse they can put shoes on a horse
and they just make sure the horse stays
sound enough for either riding or
pasture even if a horse can't be ripping
um and that's a regular shirt that needs
to be done how how
um
often
six to eight weeks and did the
promptings uh provide that to their
horses yes okay the barrier will go to
the barn yes okay about how much does it
cost every time it barrier visits each
horse
um for their horses it was about 130
each course okay and then if the course
needed uh assistance because it was
injured or sick whose responsibility is
it to get veterinary care
it is the owner's responsibility to
pay for the care
um
from the vet and
um also most of the like if it's very
involved here they should be the ones
doing it but we do offer
the services of
you know
putting appointment on a horse's moves
um that's just
and so for the most part did they did
james and jennifer make sure that was
done
i would say so yes okay i guess you
before if you've ever seen your stun
since you started your business and you
said
i have not
seen him more than maybe once or twice
okay do you know why he didn't come to
the barn with his parents for three
hours three to four times a week
i was told that he didn't really
want anything to do with the horses who
told you that
jen
oh
would you
consider
jen for a friend
i would okay and at some point
did you ever become aware of any marital
issues
she has mentioned some things in the
past
i would object as her relevance
policy your honor
according to mrna 201 and people versus
mills which is the michigan supreme
court in 1995 case evidence is relevant
if it's a material or program it issue
here is defendant's duty to protect the
community from intentionally harming
someone by willful disregarding of clear
signs of danger
what they did what they didn't do how
they spent their time what they exposed
their son to all is probative and
material and i believe it is relevant
the court is going to overwhelm the
objections go ahead
um
she had mentioned that um
she
had found some information of uh
she thought that james was cheating on
her
not singles
okay so
summer 2021 i would say so yes okay and
what was her reaction to that she was
very upset and did she tell you what she
did
as a result she confronted
james about it
and james had said that he didn't do
that
um and then even had come forward and
said that he was the one that was
looking to keep up online
okay so did she tell you that then ethan
was aware of this accusation of dancing
um i do not recall if she
said that he knew about it okay uh what
was your general impression of jennifer
i
did not have any issues with her i
i just graduated i really liked how
dedicated she was to the horses
and she
had aspirations of doing some
competitions in the summer
during show season
and
she had always treated me and everybody
else with respect that water
okay and did she talk about her slander
not a whole lot
did she ever talk about anything
positive about herself
i don't recall her
outright saying anything super positive
um
did she ever express um anything
concerning about herself
yes what did she say
she said that
he did not have any friends
that he only had one friend and
he spent a lot of time
online for playing games
but he just seemed to keep to himself
did she have a word to describe that
um not really
um
she thought that it was weird that he
wasn't out doing things like a normal
kid did she come here
what did you say did she call him weird
yes okay and
was there
a time do you remember the time frame
she told you that he didn't have any
friends
i do not remember the sign okay
did she consider him a normal
no
have you known
um
just
how she
really didn't talk a lot about them and
when she would talk about it if it was
just
you know all the
he doesn't do normal things okay did you
have any contact with jennifer or james
uh on november 30
yeah 2021
do you did either one of them to your
knowledge go to the barn on that day
uh james had gone that morning to put
some ointment out of billy's legs
what what was wrong with with billy's
legs billy has something called
um
mud fever or scratches it's a fungus
that
sometimes will grow on one's legs and it
causes scabs and it's pretty painful and
did the problem seem concerned about
billy's legs
yes okay and how do you know james was
there did you see him i did not see him
um but
some of the other people at my arm saw
him there
okay
did you have a conversation about either
on a phone or via text with jennifer
about
um anything on that day yes okay and
when you say you know james was there
was was he there in the early morning in
the afternoon do you have any idea what
time it was
i do not know exactly when i just know
that it was in the morning
because you saw that the sam was on
philly's legs yes and what time did you
notice that
um that was probably a wrong name
okay
uh
so did you ever see jennifer that day
i did not okay but she spoke what did
you do text her or call her
and did you often communicate with her
through facebook messenger yes
is that something you use normally is
there a reason why versus text um it
seems to be a lot easier for people to
just message through facebook um
i'm not totally sure why i don't really
like myself
approximately 28 pages
yes
and can you teleport what that is
um these are the messages
um that morning
of
november 30th
and who are they messages
between uh between myself and jennifer
and that's facebook messenger yes okay
can you tell the court when the messages
start and when they end
the messages start at um
10 18 am on november 30th
and
the messages end
i'm not really sure date wise but when
they
they end here
um there is no date on these but i know
that so if you can take a look at the
last couple pages last date that you see
um
where did those come from do you know
um these messages they came from my
phone okay how did they
get to
to the sheriff's party
um i had sent screenshots of my messages
because they asked you to correct yes
okay um
was jennifer
did jennifer have a lesson planned that
tuesday november 30th yes she did and
what time was this supposed to be um
well initially it was supposed to be
around
like 4 30
and then um
we
had had to push it even she said that
she could play okay we'll guess that um
so
aside from the lesson there was also
a really a big concern about billy's
legs and what did you call it non-papers
yes okay would you
would you rate the concern of the
crumbly's
pretty high about much people is that
something really serious that a horse
can get it is not super serious but it's
definitely something that needs to take
care of uh it needs to be taken care of
but um with billy's legs it was just
unusual for his legs to
swell up it became swollen
and i was all four
uh people's proposed exhibit six i
believe defense councils had a chance to
look it over and does not have an
objection no objection george
[Music]
and can you read
is it are your comments in black or are
they in blue
uh my comments are in blue okay so we
say it says november 30th and 10 18. can
you read that first text message that
you sent that day uh
boys are needing supplements for tonight
and she already lost development again
okay and then at 10 58 there was a
response from jennifer and can you read
what she responded hey i'll bring some
out later just had to go to my son's
school and meet his counselor
did you know what that was about
i did not know
then what that was about okay what
what did you
based on her describing it as shit day
what was your impression
um that
something probably happened that you
know
having problems at school
have you ever has she ever told you um
in the past that she's gone to her son's
school
she has mentioned that she has
gone through the school but i don't
recall what okay
what uh what did you respond at 11 13
kira
um
i responded with oh man everything okay
you still want to do a lesson tonight
and her response
yeah i still plan on doing the lesson
everything's okay he's just having a
hard time after losing tank his friend
going away to a treatment facility and
who knows what else but he's
and did you know about the loss of the
dog recently and a friend leaving or one
party had leaving yes okay and then she
texts you um a picture of a what looks
like a
math worksheet correct yes okay did you
look at it closely then
i
looked at it after i happened to open it
and see it that day and what was your
response to that
um well my
my response uh wait i i didn't ask that
girl what
what did you personally what was
personally your response to it what did
you think i was alarmed i thought that
was not normal
what was alarming to you about it
um
all of the violence
all over the page
it just didn't really seem like
something
that um
a kid would do on a
test in school okay were you aware that
the companies owned guns yes were you
aware that they purchased a gun to their
son
i did not know the governor's order son
do you follow the wrong situation i do
did you view a post about taking her son
to
mother sunday and a early christmas
present did you see that post i have
seen it but i'm not sure exactly when um
i don't really spend a lot of time on
social media okay me
okay uh so you you're you said you were
24 correct 25 25 i'm sorry and you
you're not a parent no but you were
really alarmed about that yes okay and
what happened after she tested you what
was the next text that came through
um
the next
the text was uh as long as i can get out
there early enough so this is from
jennifer yes okay can you speak up just
a little bit and read that yeah um as
long as i can get out there early enough
because i had to leave work for an hour
and i have a meeting in south field at
three o'clock but i should be done with
that by four i plan
being there plus the vet said it's
better for him to move around and keep
it circulating
um
while he's uh dealing with the mud fever
good times good times okay so and do you
understand based on the text messages
that she'd already met with the school
yes okay
and she's texting you about mud fever
now yes all right what was the next
textbook
um i said omg he needs some horse
therapy i bet he would love him and who
were you talking about who's he
um
okay and then what did you say after
that dad whatever works for you just let
me know i only have bella's lesson
tonight at 5 30 so anytime after her
lesson is fine
okay what was the response
okay yeah well he'll be coming out with
me tonight james is working he can't be
left alone so he can't be left alone who
did you understand her to be talking
about
i understood her to be talking about
even
and you stated one
i said that or does he want to ride
in her response and she said i don't
know maybe russia's small horse so he's
not um
intimidated
and you're suggesting mo
yes who i assume is the horse you own
i do
all right and your suggestion was what
um make it a family event coming out to
the barn really though i've seen some
amazing things done with courses with
kids
and what did jennifer say
uh he needs something
and then what else
um i
said let's make him a cowboy
and jen has responded lol mango
for real
all right here you know what happened on
november 3rd
yes when did you hear about it
i heard about it um when i got a call
from one of my students moms about what
time is that that was
in the early afternoon
do you know people
and kids that were in that school that
day i do
um i know
one
for sure um one of my students
and um i know some of
the other
kids not personally but that were
in the school also okay when you heard
about the shooting
did
was it public who was responsible for it
it was not what was your thought in
media
my thought was that it was even and tell
me why you thought it was immediate your
immediate thought wasn't even
because i know that they own guns and i
know that they go out shooting and that
math test with everything written on it
made me think that
it was
you hear again from jennifer that day
what what was the time
um here i won't be there tonight and
that came in at 2 36 in the afternoon
yes
i want you to work fully for you and she
says what yes please
and then it looks like the next uh
communication was from you at 2 58 and
you stated what i just brought in now
you're texting her a photo i assume
that's billy yes
did you text photos back and forth about
her frequently
um sometimes i would say that most of
our conversations are related to the
horses okay and you don't hear anything
back
until what time
um i don't hear anything back
from her until uh tuesday
at 4 42 and she had responded uh i need
to sell my courses
okay
so you
that day asked her if i think everything
was okay i heard there was a shooting in
oxford is even okay and then you again
respond reach out at 4 21 correct yes
and you don't reset your back until
from her until
tuesday at 4 42. so the same day and
she's saying i need to sell my horse's
death yeah okay did she go on to talk
about how much why she needs to sell her
horses no okay eventually did you
continue working this out with the does
she want does she want you to help her
sell the horses yes okay and did you do
that
i am still currently trying to help sell
them
and that that is
people's
this on the screen
just so that we know there's two
versions of that
so i want to make sure
okay
uh kieran the conversations that
occurred afterwards um
were
you seen compassion compassionate for
jennifer
at the beginning right yes okay
um
what happened
okay
and
um
you've stated a couple times in the in
the exhibit the conversations just be
honest
yes what did you mean by that
i
wanted her to be honest about
anything and everything um i
i'm a very truthful person
and um
i think that the truth
is much better than a lie okay did you
suspect what was the reason you
suspected that you might not be asked
was there something that you were
concerned about your honor i would
object that this calls for um
speculation and also the question is
presuming facts that were not not
in evidence prior to the question
response
i'm not i'm not exactly sure what the
objection is but
uh so
at some point um
did you
stop communicating with her
um i
i tried to still talk to her but i
the conversations got
fewer and far between
did jennifer ever mention
taking ethan to the doctor
no
did she ever talk about him needing to
get a physical or
he was ill and needed treatment i don't
first of all
did james ever talk about that no okay
and did you ever hear either one of them
talk about getting their son there
no
just just real quick
i i understand that your um
your farm is further more
um what's the cell coverage like there
um
is better than a lot of other farms but
there are still areas where you don't
really get great results okay but you
can
get take receive and take profits
and make calls yes and how about text
messages yes okay and did the properties
both have cell phones with them most of
the time do you know yes okay
thank you
um
what type of cell coverage do you have
um i have uh verizon which seems to be
pretty good in that area
is it fair to say that you don't know
what other cell phones like companies
how good the access is
i do not know
are there parts of the firm where people
complain they can't get messages or talk
on the phone
um
some areas you can
how big is the farm
uh the farm is on 51 acres
and in addition to the firm um there's a
separate place where you do where you do
classes is that correct
or what is groveland
groveland was the barn that we had
previously boarded at i ordered
no i met her at the previous farm before
then okay so you guys were the previous
term before then you were both at
groveland and then uh jen went on to
board her horses at your current farm i
never boarded my horses at the first
barn that i met her at that was just
where you met her yes okay
and
um you said you believe you two met in
about 2019 is that correct
i believe it was earlier than that but i
can't say for sure i don't remember
it's fair to say that horses in training
and what's going on with the horses at
the barn that's
the majority of what you and jennifer
talk about is that correct yes
um jennifer does not
talk to you about when she goes to the
doctor herself
no jennifer doesn't tell you about
james's doctor's appointments no
um jennifer
never gave you much detail about the
names of the people she worked with or
what she did at work
no
um jennifer
did jennifer ever give you details about
james like who he worked with things he
did
not a whole lot of detail i just know
that she had said that he's been through
a few different jobs okay
and as far as ethan goes um
your testimony was you have not seen him
at the barn did you ever see ethan when
he would go to groveland
i may have seen him once or twice when
they were just dropping something off it
was always a quick visit i don't know if
i've ever actually
talked to them
in person or over messages or tolerance
and it's fair to say that you talked to
jen more about horses
then ethan is that correct yes
and
um
and with respect to ethan coming um you
wouldn't have had a problem if ethan
came that day on november 30th is that
correct
i would not have had an issue with them
coming
um it would have been unusual for ethan
to come to the barn with jen on the 30th
um because he didn't normally go with
her is that correct
and on the 30th when she was planning to
bring ethan
um
you assumed she was
um upset about ethan or
had
some kind of concern for ethan is that
correct yes jen also had the option to
say to you i'm canceling the lesson i'm
not going to come i won't be there
correct yes and in her messages to you
um it was clear to you that she did not
want ethan to be alone is that correct
yes
did jennifer talk to you about
um some of the comments on the math
paperwork such as like my life is
useless
um
or the thoughts won't stop did jennifer
speak to you about any of the individual
comments
no she had just sent me the picture
um did you
were you concerned that ethan may be
suicidal after seeing these notes
yes
um prior to
the 30th when you saw this math note had
you ever been concerned that ethan would
be suicidal
no had you ever had reason to believe he
was homicidal or he would hurt other
people
no have you ever been given reason to
believe
um he was not mentally
sound that he needed
professional you know
medical help no
in terms of your um friendship with
jennifer
um
[Music]
it's fair to say when she's texting you
and she says something like lol
you understand what what she means by
those comments correct yes
so for example when she
sends a text about you send a text about
let's make ethan a cowboy is that
correct yes and she texts back mom goals
uh something along those lines correct
yes um you know that jennifer is
is kidding around and sarcastic almost
is that correct
i don't know how this witness can tell
what's in the mind of jennifer
i'll be asked a question
um did you perceive her response as
as um serious that that was a model for
her to make ethan a cowboy
um i could see her wanting to
um
be able to have her son out at the bar
and go riding a lot of parents want to
do something with their their kids and
um
that was how i took it but um a lot of
boys don't really like to ride horses
so i didn't see it as a serious
thing that would actually happen
okay you it's fair to say that you and
jennifer are able to kid back and forth
though correct yes
um with you testified that you don't see
as many boys do you see more girls
coming out to the barn for writing yes
um how many more what percentage would
you say if you were talking about young
people like teenagers are girls versus
boys
um well we currently do not have any
boys coming out to drive
really i mean um one of the other
people i've already has
a younger male student but um outside of
that there are no other boys that come
out
approximately how many girls are out of
the barn on any given day
um i would say
between two four
each day two to four each day and
really no boys is that correct yes um
when people come out to the barn is it
pretty typical if they have horses there
for them to be out there
about three to four times per week for
three hours each time
it depends on each person's situation
some people will see once a week some
people will see every single day
okay so there's nothing unusual about
three to four times a week for three
hours at a time correct
and um
it's not something that you thought was
unusual to not see ethan coming with his
mother
um out of the barn correct
all right
you certainly don't follow up with other
people who have sons that aren't present
out at the horse at the farm correct
um in the text messages with ethan uh
i'm sorry you said they were facebook
messenger messages
yes facebook messages with jennifer um
jennifer and you
go on the whole exhibit has been
admitted so the whole packet is admitted
yeah um it's fair to say that beyond
what the prosecution showed
after those messages you and jennifer
communicated about you buying billy
um
is that correct
yes i was planning to buy both billy and
jordan and you talked about buying billy
shorty the tack other horse related
items yes
okay and you um we're talking to
jennifer about how the horses could be
signed over or what you guys would need
to do is that correct yes
and
in addition to
the comments about the horses it's fair
to say that throughout the texts you
could tell jennifer was upset
yes so
for example when she said i'm balling
right now kira
um
how did you take that what did you take
that to me
she was upset and she really loved her
horses
and
when he when jennifer wrote my my son
ruined so many lives today what did you
take that to me
um
he was the shooter at oxford
and um
you reassured her that you're gonna
you'll take care of the horse and for
her to take something off her plate
correct yes
and um
you reassured her in terms of saying try
to get some rest you'll need it that
kind of thing yes
um jennifer thank you for not judging
her unlike the rest of the world
how did you take that
i
didn't really know how to take that
um you did text
jennifer
i know you and james correct yes and you
texted
this doesn't even remotely make me think
it's your fault
is that a message you sent down yes
it sounds like ethan was a troubled kid
is that correct when you said
this doesn't even remotely make me think
it's your fault what did you mean by
that
i had never gotten the feeling that um
jen and james
had those types of issues with their son
so although you knew a limited amount
about ethan because ethan wasn't someone
you frequently talked about you never
had the idea that
something like the tragedy that happened
on 11 30 could happen and ethan could be
responsible for it
you also tried to reassure her try to
stay calm and as collected as you can
um those were some messages you sent in
addition to a message that said just be
honest about everything correct yes
um
who had written billy that day he was
going to be fine helping
alleviate stress on that and for john is
that correct yes
when jennifer texted you and said i wish
we had warnings something
he's a good kid
they made a terrible decision
how did you
what did you think after getting that
text
i was thinking there had to have been
some type of science um she had
mentioned in the past like you know that
he really didn't have friends he didn't
go out and do
fun things like
um kids his age
so i
well
the text is from
her to you saying i wish we had warnings
something
he's a good kid
they made a terrible decision
um you didn't point out to her things
that you thought may have been signs in
the past correct correct
um
you actually wrote there probably were
warnings but nobody saw them correct yes
and you said hindsight is always 2020.
yes
and we can all agree looking back
um
when something bad happens we look back
at what could have prevented it correct
yes
[Music]
when
jennifer said he's a good kid you didn't
write back to her anything like well
actually your son is not a good kid
correct
and although he didn't hang out with
friends um you were aware that he had
one friend who's particularly close to
correct yes
and
um on facebook
throughout jen's profile you said you
were uh social media contact with her is
that correct yes you can you can see
could you see pictures of them going
camping and taking even places i did see
posts about them doing things with them
so there were posts about uh the family
spending time together camping um going
places on the weekend correct yes
and um
you testified you understood he played a
lot of video games is that correct yes
and that never struck you as something
that was overly problematic correct no
um you had no reason to ever say to jen
like hey john wake up there are signs or
anything like that
after um
you were aware that ethan
had been the shooter
um
you and jennifer um attempted to
talk to each other on the phone do you
recall that yes
and do you recall that jennifer said you
had to call her through facebook
um because she has to use a track phone
yes
at that point did you and jennifer have
a telephone conversation
okay so in the facebook messenger thread
when it says like you missed a call from
jc i assume jc is jennifer crumley yes
and then it says um call me back on
facebook i'm on a track phone i need to
talk and figure some things out you and
jennifer didn't have any phone contact
at that point you did not
and when jennifer was on that track
phone she said it would be easier
because texting on that phone is hard if
you guys could talk correct yes
um
further down you
you continue to let her know that billy
was fine
had a good ride with him correct yes
and at that point you became concerned
about
jennifer
coming out to the farm is that correct
yes why were you concerned with jennifer
coming to the farm
because i did not want them to
um
take
things
um that were owned by other borders or
myself
you didn't want jennifer to take things
that were owned by other voters or
yourself
correct did you um
were you concerned about the safety of
people at the farm if jennifer and james
showed up
yes
were you concerned because jennifer
showed you some of the threatening
messages she had received yes
and
when you explained to jennifer you were
concerned and wanted the police to be
out there
you actually wrote i don't want people
to follow you or hurt you correct yes
and you said we just need to be careful
yes
so nothing about
any horse equipment or concerns
no
um and were you afraid that people
were going to follow the crumblings out
to the farm and possibly hurt people
i was worried about that
um
after that
um discussion about the police mrs
probably made it
clear that they were headed to a safe
place for a couple days is that correct
yes they did not tell you she did not
say the location they were going to just
a safe place
yeah she had said that it's a hotel or
hotel in here and that was i don't know
where exactly they've gone and then your
messages to her where i'm very glad
you're safe i care about you guys
correct yes was that true yes
and again you reassure her i will take
care of your boys let me know when you
want me to buy them and i'll buy them if
you were trying to figure out something
to see if you could buy them is that
right yes
you also said if you need anything just
let me know correct yes
doing all the things that you could do
as a friend to jennifer
um and jennifer wanted to make sure the
horses didn't end up in a bad situation
too as far as you can tell yes
and as you're texting her about the
horses and everything else um
and a little bit about what's going on
after finding out about the shooting
you didn't follow up with her about what
her work arrangements were
no you didn't follow up with her about
what if james was still working or what
he was doing
no
you didn't follow up with her about any
other kind of personal issues related to
her
all you followed up about is what we can
see in the tasks yes
so
it's fair to say that your friendship
with jennifer was pretty limited to
horses care for horses and maybe just
some friendly chit chat correct yes
looking back you're not looking at
conversations regarding ethan
um
as anything where you should have
contacted law enforcement correct
correct nothing where you should have
had an alarm go off and say oh i should
call the police about this one correct
even the day that you saw the drawing
that's up on the board
um
you didn't contact law enforcement to
say i just saw like a really crazy
drawing or anything along those lines i
did not and if anything um jennifer
appeared to be very concerned about what
was going on correct
yes
when jennifer um
had ever been out to the school or not
you weren't aware of every time jennifer
had ever been over to oxford high is
that fair to say
correct
so that day um stuck out as something
unusual
yes
um you guys were attempting to put
together um cash
that
that you were potentially going to pay
her for horses is that correct yes
ultimately the two of you
never physically met up is that correct
all right so the extent of all of your
communications is contained within these
28 pages of facebook messenger messages
yes you already testified there were no
phone calls and there was no personal
like one-on-one contact yes
i just need my name
i have nothing further on behalf of
jennifer crumbly any questions that we
have james cumberland yes thank you
did i pronounce that correctly
yes thank you um you testified that you
didn't speak to james very often did you
yes
that's correct you did not speak to him
and when you did it was about the horses
is that fair yes force-related matters
correct yes um he didn't tell you that
he had to go to the doctor or anything
right no he didn't tell you that jen had
been to the doctor
no he didn't talk about ethan's medical
appointment no so similar to jen he kept
his communications with you about forces
and force-related matters is that fair
yes
and you didn't reach out to
james after seeing this picture from jen
and say i'm really concerned about ethan
right i did not and you testified
previously that
your communications with jen or or
james
you never were
you never were concerned about ethan is
that fair
correct
there were there was never anything that
you saw
that gave you cause to be concerned
about ethan's mental health right
now
and when again when you did talk to
james
it was limited to
horses and related matters yes
so it wasn't strange that he didn't talk
about
work right correct or doctor's
appointments
yeah or ethan
his relationship with you was because of
the horses yes
nothing further judge thank you can you
rejoice
briefly
you know uh you just testified that we
didn't your i believe the testimony was
you kept your conversations to friendly
chit-chat is that right
yes except that she did talk to you
about her husband here
she never said that he had an affair she
just had a feeling she had a family and
she did talk to you about her son being
here
yes and she did talk to you about the
fact that he only had one friend
yes and she did talk to you about how he
didn't like horses yes okay and then all
the time that you've met jennifer and
jason you've known them how many times
have you seen either
maybe once or twice okay let me ask you
this did both parents have to go to the
barn every time for three to four times
a week three hours at a time
they did not have to go together fair to
say
some of that stuff all of that stuff
could have been done by one person
yes okay and
when you
told miss smith that um
jennifer was very concerned um she still
did though have the time to text you
about billy's mud fever
and
arrange the lesson and then cancel the
lesson yes okay and when you said you
told her it's not your fault and you you
know time size 2020 at that time that
you stated that did you know that um
that they purchased a gun for ethan and
it was accessible to him i did not know
that the gun was
or
objection your honor about
[Music]
did you did you know that jennifer
texted ethan the day before um about the
ammunition search hello well
i did not know did you know that uh
that the school
told jennifer and james they needed to
get new therapy i did not know did you
know that when they heard about a
shooting that james went home to look to
see if that gun was there i did not did
you know he called 911
[Music]
any objection
no judge thank you not from mr crump
clearance
what's up
because the screenshots
please have a seat
as close as possible to those
microphones they do amplify your voice
along with record your voice it's very
important for you to respond to all
questions verbally um please refrain
from that in your head or saying aha
because it's difficult
keep your voice up so everybody can hear
you that would be helpful
um i will leave it up to you as to
whether or not you're comfortable
removing your mask you want to remove
your nest
so you may as you can see we do have
plexiglass around the witness stand
um and
keep it on okay
i'm sorry
it's going to be tough to hear yeah and
then you do need to keep your voice up
there okay okay if you could please
state and spell with your first and last
name for the right andrew smith
thank you council
mr smith you're a lawyer right correct
in fact you practice in front of this
judge and you're familiar
and can you tell me what your
position is now
i work as chief operations officer for
real estate company okay and what are
your duties
manage the operations
of the counseling of the portfolio
and how many employees are in the
company
approximately 700. all right do you know
jennifer crumley yes
all right do you see jennifer probably
in the courtroom here yes
describe something she's wearing
she's wearing black and white
were you her direct
supervisor i was
most recently but now when she was hired
okay so for how long you her supervisor
how many years ago
i think
all right and what were her
responsibilities
she was a marketing director
director what what does that entail what
what kinds of mediums or um services has
oversee responsible for marketing the
property the asset and responsible for
social media
for reviews ratings
online reviews website related materials
working with third-party vendors
working with the properties on their
internal external marketing portfolio
and things like that
okay she the the company has uh all
social media
yes we have a large social media
platform
work hours
standard uh 40 hours a week i think she
came in at 8 o'clock
or before leave around 4 o'clock
was that the same every day
i believe so for the most part yes and
in your company do employees have to
choose which hours they work and work
the same time a day or is it flexible
it's so much flexible being heard we
want a 40-hour weekly work week
eight-hour days and you get some
flexibility
and do you allow employees to work from
home
we ask when needed yes
[Music]
yes very much
i think we're very family friendly if
there's ever a need or a time for a
family issue it's always in grants
okay
um
taking you back to november 30th uh do
you remember that day i do
and do you remember having any contact
with jennifer crumpling
i do
can you tell the court what was your
first nonsense
i received a text message from miss
crumley that warning about 10 a.m was it
a text or facebook messenger a text
message
is that how you normally communicated
with her
in person by email or
phone messengers oh text message yes yes
test
by
about approximately what time was that
you know
and what were you doing at the time
striving okay um
i think at this point i'd like to
approach the people's proposed
eight and i believe there's a
stipulation to it
okay bro yes and that's
um exactly what time did you first hear
from her
and
you were aware of the time i was driving
my vehicle okay did you
um get a good look at the text
i saw that you touched me while driving
that she was going through her child's
school counseling okay was that
something that she's required to do she
leaves work
she's you're supposed like your
supervisor will know if you're going to
need any mortgages okay and
um respond no
all right
okay so
the
the worksheet which has also previously
been exhibited um entered into evidence
she also attached the the math worksheet
correct correct yes
all right and what exactly do you read
the test that she sent
i have to go to my kid's school
counselor just called and this is what
i'm dealing with so i'll be back by 11
30 12 at the latest
and then
what was the next communication you had
with jennifer public i believe i
saw her at work around you in that day
did you take a good look at that
worksheet not that i mean i did but at
that time okay
so you said you saw her later at work do
you know what time that was just passed
me 12 now okay and who are you here
um i saw in the copy room in our office
and just to stop you did you um know
anything about
first time
no nothing more than maybe small talk
okay did you
did she ever talk about her son with you
not really no maybe some small attack
here but not much
did she talk about anything um that she
did outside
very little she talked about horses and
she owned horses and she would enjoy
horses
maybe vacation or there a little travel
but not a lot
okay
uh so
the next time you saw jennifer i'm sorry
you said
it was around 12 pm
okay and what was the did you have a
conversation with her yes and what was
the um conversation about our class for
how things were how she was doing and
she had
she her son needed to get some
counseling
and
uh i think she mentioned his
dog
family had it passed away and a
grandparent had passed away recently
and she felt like she was failing
i'm sorry she said what i think she said
she felt like she was failing him or a
failure
all right when she said she had to get
counseling did she say why no oh she
said
she didn't say why she just mentioned
that family pettit passed away a
grandparent had passed away
yeah but she didn't say why did she tell
you um what the situation was at school
no just said she was told she needed to
get some constant personality okay and
her son was not going through right
now
by the way you do a lot of kids come to
your workplace right this happened yeah
um
can you tell the court what was on
jennifer crumbley's
schedule that day
i know we had a meeting scheduled to
visit the coffee that afternoon and and
did you talk to her about going to
yes when did you speak with her
i mean they've talked before the 30th
where we talked that day that afternoon
where did you have a conversation
shortly after we talked
in the coffee room so maybe 20 minutes
half hour later heard another colleague
and i had a brief conversation about a
property visit that afternoon
and about some phone calls we scheduled
the next day and was she required to go
to that meeting
she was invited not required did you
tell her
no did you tell her she didn't have that
at that meeting i mentioned to her she
was her choice she did not even come i
did say that yes okay
and if she had not returned
to work that afternoon
what would have happened to jennifer
formally at her workplace
i'm confused if she's been disciplined
that she didn't come back to work that
afternoon after what point after she
went to the school of queensland i don't
know not at all okay what what is the uh
protocol if somebody has to leave for an
issue with their child or something else
well we have a pto policy but when it
comes to what is pto standpoint paid
time off okay um which you would submit
your time on an online portal but if you
had a family issue you would always be
granted time for a family whatever maybe
okay and did she ever request to leave
that day
um after she went to school and came
back
she never requested but she did be that
day yes okay we're gonna get to that
um
what was the next time
that you spoke to
jennifer after
uh you had a meeting about
um
yeah i heard some loud yelling screaming
what did you do
i heard it i was i think i was on a
caller's zoom and i
walked out of my office to see what was
going on
and i saw her miss from this mrs from to
say that there was an active shooter in
child school and she had to go and did
she leave she did and i assume you
didn't have a problem with that yes
okay well did you hear from her again
one day
yes
uh can you tell where
what how did you hear my
do you know what time those occurred
i received a text message about 20-30
minutes after she laughed okay let's um
we have the exhibit published
and can you read that text that came in
1 23 p.m correct okay
do you know if you know how long after
uh how long it was from the time she
left to the time she's done that text i
think 20 30 minutes okay can you read
the text
the gun is gone and soar the bullets
okay
what
can she text the gun is gone so were the
bullets
did you know anything about about the
gun at this point not at all no and what
what did you think when you received
that
i didn't know what she was saying i was
concerned
okay and what happened after that
i texted her back i said i'm praying
everything is okay i didn't know what to
say
did you know that there was a gun or
bullets in the home at all not them no
yeah what not that i was aware of no
okay so had you had a previous
conversation with jennifer crumbly about
funds none that i recalled no okay and
are you do you follow her on social
media yes the time i did okay and did
you do you regularly look at her post
i don't regularly but i see your post i
would see your post time to time yes did
you ever remember seeing a post about
that
i remember seeing the post by shooting
before the 30th i don't recall before
after i don't i don't know okay and
what did she respond
what did the phone call the first phone
call
it was about 1 30 1 25 30. so was it
before the next test
[Music]
our hr director's office
okay when i received this text i i was
actually in a hearing on a zoo meeting
and i stepped away because i was
concerned about what i had just received
and
walk down to our hr director's office
in her office i received the phone call
and did you have the phone on speaker or
did you just call anywhere i took the
comment on speaker okay and what did
jennifer say
i would her saying she was trying to get
to her child's school
she saw her frantic her ambulance or
sirens in the background
and that the gun was missing
when she said
she said that my husband is at home and
already
okay and then did the call line right
then or was there more conversation i
don't recall more i think it ended
shortly after we might have said you
know please let us know if you need
anything but i would call exactly
okay
and
um
after that then you receive the next
test
yes yes i believe so and what does it
say
omg andy he's going to kill himself he
must be the shooter
and then the next guest i need a lawyer
with police
and then what else ethan did it
okay
what was your response at this point
complete shock
and what what did you do
i i was i loved hr director now at the
time um
we didn't really know what to do we were
looking for the story online to see if
everyone was okay do you know what was
going on we were really concerned
greatly concerned and shocked what we
were learning did she
make another phone call to you yes do
you know when that occurred that was
about
2 2 15.
okay so
there was a
what was the 215 call about who was the
president i was again i was in our hr
director's office i put on speaker and
she had said she saw this on the police
station
her caller's saying that and i recall
her saying that she asked if i could
refer to a recommended lawyer what did
you say
at the time i couldn't think of anything
i didn't think of awareness i told her
i'd ask our corporate counselor
why couldn't you think of a work i said
you know a lot of works
i received a text at 3 39 p.m
okay and what's the text say
i need my job please don't judge me
and what did you think about that
i was
surprised by that task
i was surprised she was worried about
her job at the time i thought she'd be
more worried about what was going on
and at that point was it was
just for clarification i know that this
exhibit was
stipulated wanted the record to be
quoted
it's probably
mr smith at some point that meeting you
spoke of that um this is crumbly
would you consider it optional that she
fucked that me
yeah she was invited she did not have
two times did they actually take place
no
thank you
um good afternoon
uh my name is shannon smith i am a
lawyer representing jennifer crumley um
if i ask any confusing questions please
let me know okay
um
you testified that um the company is
family friendly correct correct if
people need time off to do things for
their children um your company's
flexible and allows that to happen yes
and um
[Music]
in terms of with uh jennifer crumley you
were aware ethan was her son yes
and while you didn't discuss ethan very
often um
she
she didn't make it any secret she had
ethan as her son correct i knew she had
a son
yes okay and did you see that she had
photographs of him playing soccer up in
her office
it sounds familiar yes
and most of what you and jennifer talk
about in the grand scheme of things is
work-related uh issues correct yes would
you describe jennifer as being somebody
who's very conscientious about her work
yes and would you agree with me that
she's a definite go-getter wanting to
get promotions wanting to make more
money wanting to get further ahead
she was definitely professional and very
good she was better job and handled
herself very well yes the position that
she was in at the on november 30th
that position i think you said was
director of marketing is that correct
right
and the director role was actually a
newer role for jennifer
um
is that correct
yes i believe she had been in that
position about a year and a half okay so
prior to her being in that position she
was in a lower position and she had
worked up to being the director
yes
um and it's fair to say jennifer
appears to be a hard worker
i believe so yes
and um
[Music]
okay so
you were you've been in touch with her
um and working with her the entire time
she's been employed at the company
correct
she didn't report to me until she became
the director of
all right thank marxism
when um you were talking to jennifer and
um she mentioned she had to go over to
the school counselor
um you testified that she said something
about i feel like a failure is that
correct yes how what did you take that
to me
i didn't know i didn't know i think she
just felt sad about the situation
um did she seem um nervous or upset
anything like that
she seems somewhat down
okay
so she left work and she went over to
the school
and i believe the text
or you unders did she tell you she was
going to the school or was it just the
text that i have to go to my kids school
i just received the text
and
have their
was it frequent that you would get texts
from her that she had to go to the
school to see the counselor
i don't recall any other tax regarding a
counselor
was there ever um other times that
were there
other times where jennifer had to go
over and meet with people at the school
as far as you know i don't know
um it's fair to say that jennifer having
to go over to the school that wasn't
something that consistently disrupted
work
not that recall no
um
so you testified she went over the
school and then did you say there was a
phone call after she left the school
or what was what was the next phone call
i received a phone call from her that
afternoon
okay and that afternoon the phone call
you described her as being frantic
yes okay tell me what you mean by that
she seemed very alarmed and concerned
did she seem upset
she seemed very alarmed
i guess you could say upset yes but it
was more that she was in a frantic
concern
and was that when she was it was your
understanding she was trying to get to
the child's school
yes
um and it was in that phone call where
she told you that there was a gun and
that uh james had already called the
police about the gun is that correct
correct
at that point in time um
did you and jennifer discuss any other
issues
not that i recall okay was it a
a conversation that was
frantic in terms of fast paced or was it
was it slower paced do you recall how
that call was i just recall she was
frantic you tell very alarmed okay and
obviously that concerned you
absolutely
when um
when you received the text
uh that said oh my god andy he's going
to kill himself he must be the shooter
um
[Music]
what did you take that text to mean
i don't know how to answer i was very
alarmed by this stuff
ethan
um
being suicidal was that something that
you had ever discussed with jennifer
crumbly no
ethan um
being a shooter of any person or
being thought to be
homicidal was that something you had
ever discussed with jennifer no
ted had you ever had thoughts in your
mind that
based on what jennifer said in front of
you that ethan
would be a school shooter
no
as far as you are aware
jennifer is the breadwinner in the home
is that a fair statement
i don't know
you so you don't discuss the details of
jane's employment or what james does
with him
i've never discussed anything with james
before
okay or and as far as you know
jennifer's never giving you details
about his employment or anything like
that i believe she may have mentioned he
got laid off and was in between jobs at
one point i remember that yes okay um as
far as john not talking to you about
ethan frequently that wasn't something
that um rubbed you as strange correct no
um
there was no time where you ever went to
jennifer and said i'm i'm really
concerned about your son or the way you
handle or don't handle your son is that
correct
that's impressive
your relationship with jennifer just
isn't one where that kind of
uh conversation would be normal
that's a fair statement yes
you testified that you were in complete
shock is that correct
at least yes
um did you when in talking to jennifer
on the phone calls and
um
through the text messages
did you
have an opinion about whether she seems
like she was in shock
are you asking one shoot on the phone
yeah or through the text messages
well i can't speak to how she felt in
the task on the phone she definitely
signed a transition
and when um the prosecution asked you
about
the text where jennifer said i need my
job please don't judge me for what my
son did
um you recall that text correct
and you testified that you thought it
was strange to be worried about that
with everything going on is that correct
yes it's fair to say that you don't know
what she was worried about in that
moment um except for in part her job
correct
what
she had called us prior to that letting
us know that she was at the police
station and saw her son i figured she
was worried about her child
okay so we can agree that while she was
worried about her job she could have
been worried about many other topics at
the same time
sure yes okay and
um in your conversations with her you
did understand her to be worried about
other things such as ethan
being at the police station
lawyers things along those lines
that was where she was worried about her
son yes
ryder i have nothing further for miss
crumbling this time any questions of
any uh cross board james comey not your
honor
any of you drugs briefly mr smith at
some point did you have a chance to go
back and look at that worksheet
at some point yes i did when did you do
that
later that afternoon and what did you
did you look at it in detail
yes i looked at it after you learned
what happened and what was your thought
about it
it's trouble
it's concerning
it's a concerning message it looks like
someone's trying for help
when you say that it looks like someone
uh asking for help
that could be a concern of suicide is
that correct
i'm not sure i can't say i think for
sure i guess yes
when someone writes um help me and my
life is useless
that was concerning us
thank you
briefly your honor did you see the
picture of the gun
yes did you know that it was identical
to the gun that they bought their son no
okay
thank you he stepped down
uh
i'm gonna take i'm gonna take about a
five minute break
okay
[Music]
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
one
that is correct but my understanding is
um and i just want to make sure this is
correct number five is going to be
played that's okay i'm sorry number five
played in the courtroom
but all five events in terms of the
admissibility of them you have
stipulated to the admission of all facts
yes
um
the issue that you want to address with
the court before we start do you post it
up at the bench
very quickly um when my client is seated
and writing down on her lap the camera
can focus in on her papers and
it has
um i would ask that the cameras not be
allowed to focus on papers and the media
explicitly be told that cannot happen
um
thank you
okay we are back on the record on people
versus jennifer chromeblade and people
versus james crumbly um the defense
console has brought up an issue relative
to
any filming and or photographing of
notes taken by the by the attorneys and
or the defendants
i am going to direct the media do not
zero in or take any photographs of their
notes to each other that is prohibited
strictly prohibited and that is
attorney-client communication and it is
not to be divulged in any way shape or
form
okay
okay you're ready to call your next
witness prosecution
captain paul
yes
you can have a sequence
if you could scoot as close as you can
to those microphones i'd appreciate it
um i am going to ask you please keep
your voice up when testifying so that
everybody can hear you and we can record
you additionally it is um it's very
important for you to verbalize all
responses okay if you shake your head or
say uh-huh on my court reporter cannot
record that okay
okay so again i'm going to ask you to
keep your voice up yes all right um
first i'd like you to state and spell
your first and last name for me
kathy poliquin k-a-t-h-y
p-o-l-i-q-u-i-n thank you
go ahead council
kathy just for purposes of
playing the groundwork here you work for
a real estate management company correct
okay what's your title there director of
human resources okay and again
remembering to try to match the volume
of my voice um what are your what do you
overseas what are your tools
i oversee all human resource functions
all the employees in all of our
locations including our corporate office
anything dealing with payroll benefits
um
disciplinary hiring firing anything
human resource related and how long have
you done that jeff 16 years okay do you
know jennifer
yes do you know james from here no do
you see jennifer here in the courtroom
yes can you describe something she's
wearing her
what she's wearing a black and white
jumpsuit nathan remember that
when did you first meet jennifer crumbly
almost five years ago
is that when she began working there yes
all right and when she was hired what
was her position
marketing assistant
what was her position at the time she
left she was terminated
and what was your
interaction
just a few facebook
texts
um
casual okay were you friends
friendly friends
and did she ever share anything
personally
with you very minimal
did you what did you know about her
based on what she told you
yeah uh i know she loves horses
i know that she worked at the
ski patrol
i said what
and just minimally giving me some
information when her husband had lost a
job
and took a job with four dash
and when did she tell you he took the
job with george
a few months ago
did you know she had a son yes
did she talk about him much
no
did you um would you describe your
workplace family friendly yes
our core values is family first
so what exactly is that
if anybody needed to
attend to a family issue they had to
leave for an emergency it was never said
no you know go attend to your your
concerns or your problems
and
and that's it we never you know held
anyone back and did you um did jennifer
directly report to you no so when did
you interact with her
was it
hey hours time off
sometimes usually she would help me with
employment and postings on social media
okay
and
when employees need to take time off
what's the procedure
procedure they are to ask permission
from their immediate supervisor first
and then they enter their time into the
payroll system for pto patient law and
has eto accumulated
it is upon higher they would have earned
40 out 48 hours at 90 days
and then at one year of employment they
would earn 88 hours of pto
two years they would earn 120 hours of
pto in five years and beyond it would be
160
and as part of your job do you keep
trying with that yeah i do through our
payroll system do you manage um the
documents and records related to
benefits and
time off and employment yes okay do you
do you know if jennifer had any pto time
on november 30th
meaning if she had to take time off what
was that available to her yes i believe
she had 12 hours of pto remaining at
that
time do you follow jennifer on social
media
i am facebook friends i don't
really follow
does the company offer health insurance
yes does it offer health insurance for a
single person and a family yes
was jennifer's son covered under health
insurance no
was jennifer covered on her health yes
was james no
does your
policy provide any assistance or
insurance for mental health treatment
yes
you said you uh are associated with
jennifer on social media did you ever
see a post about a gun
yes do you remember when you saw that
i don't know exactly when it was in the
past couple months okay and um
what what was your reaction
to the post about the gun and her son
[Music]
uh
did jennifer ever talk to you about guns
no did she ever talk to you about her
son
no
do you know jennifer was at work on
november 29th
yes
you know that first summer or
it was recorded that she was at work it
was recorded on her time
okay did you see jennifer on november
30th
no did you talk to her yes
and do you know she came into work that
day
no
you don't know or she didn't no i don't
know okay i didn't understand okay so
but at some point you talked where one
how did that come about i only talked to
her when andy smith came into my office
and he had
done on his cell phone
and what was jen do you remember about
what time that was
okay
what was jennifer saying on the phone
she was very hysterical i don't recall
verbatim
very hysterical she was trying to get to
the school
i believe she was talking about you know
the gun is missing
when she said the gun did you know what
gun she was talking about i was assuming
it was
her handgun
that was i saw on social media you're
assuming it was the same gun that was
posted on instagram
on early christmas presents
okay and
did you ever see
the
worksheet
yes when did you see it
i saw it at the same time andy smith
came into my office put it down on the
phone
he put his cell phone down and pulled up
a picture of that on his phone
and did you take a good look at it he
did
when
well
what was your thought
my first thought was this what means
help
okay did you say anything about it no
you were just listening
and at some point
did you talk to jennifer again that day
yes how many times
maybe
one or two i don't recall how many
and what was the purpose of the did she
call you or did you mother
told me i did not call her okay and will
you ever adopt any calls that she and
amy had
okay what was the purpose of the cause
from jennifer i recall one conversation
she was afraid to lose her job do you
remember what time that was i don't
recall the exact time
was it during the work hours it was
during workout okay
and what was your response
our response was to
attend to your family
and
don't worry about work
just tend to your family let's talk
about it next week
did you get another request to come to
about work yes and what was it
it was uh same request that she didn't
want to lose her job she was afraid to
lose her job
and
another senior leadership nancy lutfey
was with us on the phone
has been stated that she was going to be
on administrative leave
for the next couple weeks
and just to not worry about about work
what did you say
thank you she said to tell our
senior leadership thank you
did she wanted to come in
she thought she could possibly come in a
few days later maybe for a half a day to
get her mind off things later that week
the day in the week of the shooting
yes what day was this tuesday
yes first thursday or friday so she
wanted to come in back to work that week
what was your response she said no
you're on an administrative need
don't don't worry about coming into the
world we'll talk and please
and did you ever hear jennifer asked to
leave work to take ethan to
the doctor
no do you know
did she ever talk about him getting any
kind of medical
no all right did she ever talk about her
horses getting medical attention
uh
i think a few times she had mentioned
the vet
the horse was sick
um
i want to go through the um
november 30th date with you
um
when you were with
it sounds like andy smith um
and he came into your office with
jennifer on the phone do you recall that
yes
and you testified that she was
hysterical did i get that right right
can you describe what it means when you
can you describe what you mean by that
i don't recall exactly what she was
saying i know she was just very upset
she was trying to get to the school
uh i believe she said the roads were
closed off she was having a difficult
time
getting there
we
said to her call the police she said
james already did the gun was missing
but she was
she was just
um
i i can't put i i don't recall exactly
what she said that she was just
really um upset and hysterical did she
sound panicked
yeah yes was she talking fast
yes
um
you you and andy were trying to just get
her to at least stay calm is that
correct yes
was it it was a separate phone call um
when judd was asking if she still had
her job is that correct yes and she told
you part of the reason she didn't wanna
she she told you she didn't know how to
handle this correct yes and
she doesn't know she told you
um she needed information from you so
that she could get money to pay for a
lawyer is that correct
uh yes i think she wanted czech stones
you would be the person to contact for
check stubs or verification of
employment correct yes
and jennifer explicitly said she needs
to get a loan
to pay to pay to have a lawyer correct
yes so any kind of check stubs or
uh documents you needed to prepare
she would have asked you for those
materials correct
as an active employee she still had
access to her checkstones she just had
to log into the payroll system
okay but if like for example
a loan officer needed documentation or
something as the hr person you you can
send those materials along correct yes
you
now as you were talking to
uh miss crumbly she also
sent you a different email address
um to send
uh any materials to from her pay stubs
and things like that correct yes she
indicated you her outlook isn't working
um and she needed you to use this other
address yes
so the bulk of your conversation is
really about these logistics about
pay stubs this is happening and in the
background you know she's driving to the
school she's frantic
trying to get there correct
she wasn't driving to the school about
the conversation with check stubs i'm
sorry so the check subs conversation was
after she had already been at the school
yes it's fair to say during that
conversation she still sounded upset and
not like her normal self she was upset
not as
hysterical as she was
um when you spoke with police you told
them how um jennifer had offered to come
back to work do you recall that
yes and specifically you said that
jennifer said she wanted to come back to
work maybe half days the following week
do you recall telling law enforcement
guy
i don't recall but
i may have does that sound accurate it
sounds good
um
if anything you and anyone else from the
company um that you were with that day
was supportive to jennifer crumbly
correct yes um everyone at your office
that you were around that day was
surprised by what was taking place at
oxford school high school
mr crumpley was also asking you
questions about how much is in her 401k
things along those lines correct yes
and she's trying to get the company id
for sites like paylocity is that a
a
payroll company you use yes
um
you were trying to help her with that
because even that site was having issues
that day is that correct yes
so a lot of your conversations with jen
regarding her employment
um
hr issues
those are not topics that would surprise
you that jennifer would call you about
correct
if jennifer
in the past was having an argument with
ethan or something along those lines
that's not something jennifer would have
come and talk to you about correct yes
if she had done that that would be
unusual
yes we didn't have that kind of
relationship so you had um certainly a
professional relationship
yes where the questions about her job
payroll pay stubs proof of employment
were relevant to what you do for the
company yes
um your office is not far from
jennifer's where jennifer sits is that
correct
it is a good distance away
you've been down by her desk yes and
you've seen that she has family
photographs and things like that yes
on her facebook
feed you saw the photograph um of the
gun
in a post from jennifer uh days before
is that correct right
and you never spoke with jennifer about
that post
no
um you testified that it was um
it was not appropriate
um
it would not be appropriate in your mind
for you to post something like that is
that correct
um it's fair to say you're not into guns
right it's fair to say you don't go to
the shooting range and enjoy that kind
of a hobby correct
and um
the
based on jennifer's facebook there were
pictures of uh targets after they had
gone to a shooting range you saw those
as well yes
okay and you saw the photograph of the
guy yes
um
in terms of facebook overall jennifer
also posted about vacations camping
trips things along those lines is that
correct
she may have i really did i don't really
read people's feet since i don't know
okay did you go back and look at her
feed since um since the time that since
november 30th when everything unfolded
no
if i told you that there are photographs
family photographs things like that
would you be surprised no
when was it that you saw the math page
um during the day of november 30th who
showed you that that page andy smith
read it on his phone when he came into
my office
and then he pulled that up while she was
talking
did that happen when um
before or after the first call when
jennifer was on her way to the school
that was the first call
that i had i was on the phone
and i'm sorry so you saw this photograph
before that that phone call
no
i'm sorry tell me the order of the
events i'm missing it yeah edie smith
came into my office
and put jen on the speaker phone was the
first i've heard of anything
and he brought that picture up on his
phone at that time while she was
talking hysterically trying to drive to
the school
you did not talk to her though about the
contents of that page anything on there
correct
it was the kind of thing where you're
having a conversation on speakerphone
and andy was showing you what jennifer
had said to him right
and when when you looked at it you
thought um
that boy needs help is that correct
right
and when you saw that drawing um
and knew that there was something going
on where mom was heading to the school
you didn't call police or anyone to make
anyone aware about this drawing is that
correct i did not call correct
and at that point um
[Music]
when you were speaking to jennifer
jennifer didn't go over the details on
the on the drawing with you
no
when you were on the phone and uh andy
and you
uh had a conversation
um
were you were you aware that jennifer
was concerned ethan may be suicidal
yes did you become concerned that he was
suicidal
i i
too much was going on i didn't really
have time to think i was trying to
process what was going on
i did not know
the whole story
you would agree with me that that day
when you were dealing with jennifer
crumbly
she was processing a lot too and it was
a it was an unordinary day is that
correct yes
thank you
any questions
and pay stubs and you responded
that you weren't correct
okay but were you surprised that just a
couple hours after her son
murdered children in a school she's
asking about her job
yes and she also asked you about
pictures did anything strike you unusual
when you actually
uh
cleaned out jennifer's desk
unusual
slightly what was that
maybe approach please
what if any
[Music]
and the only other photos i saw and
found was a small picture of the sun on
her bulletin board
and a picture of a universe
if it was her horse or whatnot
please
oh
so
okay
so
the calling people versus james and
jennifer probably got the numbers two
one zero zero
good afternoon
on behalf of jennifer crumbly good
afternoon your honor marielle layman on
behalf of james crumbly
and we're ready to proceed with your
examination i am runner
how's amanda
[Music]
you're going to
please keep your voice up
verbalize all responses to all questions
and if you are comfortable you can take
your mask
you have to flex the glass around on
both sides so it's totally up to you
all right i'm going to ask you to state
and spell both your first and last name
thank you
amanda just if you try to match the
volume of my voice then you should do
fine so everybody can hear you
uh you're employed a real estate
management company yeah and what is your
uh
position there
[Music]
do you have an office or a desk um
and do you know uh jennifer
do you know james
no
and do you see jennifer crumbly in the
courtroom here today yeah can you
describe something she's wearing
um a striped
top
okay may the record reflect that she's
not properly identified no objection
how close in proximity is your
workstation
to
was your workstation to the jennifer's
uh very close across the hall
and machine in office or people
okay
and are you are you jennifer are you in
jennifer friends
no
okay how would you describe your
relationship
um
co-workers friendly supporters did you
ever socialize with her outside the
office
and did you
have opportunities to interact with her
on a daily basis
yes
okay
and
would
you share personal uh details about your
your lives
together on the page of each other okay
who did more of the sharing you or
jennifer
okay
and
um
did she share with you any personal
problems that she was having yeah okay
can you give give me um an example of
something
um
you have to speak up really loud or take
your message off so you can see but you
can keep that's gone
um marital issues
okay
and you did you know who her husband was
and she talked about him by name yes and
who was that
okay and when did that um come up
um
occasionally um approximately what year
what month um
2021. um i she spoke with him
occasionally just you know throughout
the time i know her um but more in
detail
okay and is this something that she
would talk to you about because she was
upset or in passing
so all right and what uh aside from
things that she said to you were there
other other any other side that there
was a dispute or conflict between
james and jennifer
talking to me about yes
um
there would be a lot of phone calls
occasionally um
but that was about it i'm sorry what
loud phone calls occasionally but other
than that though loud phone calls that
she would keep the door open um
sometimes
um usually it would be shot around
um
you could still hear the conversation
behind the closed door yes okay
uh
what
you said they were having marital issues
what what exactly did she tell you
um
that
both her and james i've been seeing
other people
and was that something she was happy
about
um not at first
but then it didn't seem like it was an
issue
okay did she tell you that they were
still together
um
they had separated for a moment
but then it sounded like they had gotten
back together and when they separated do
you remember when about a month or a
year that was it was 20 21 but i don't
recall
that
did they separate hustles
no that's my knowledge okay
um and
was there any other um
indicator to you that there were other
relationships going on
than just with her husband
yeah
what was that
[Music]
yes
uh
the defendants own a duty to the
community to prevent their sons who they
had every reason to believe and solve
was a danger what they did and didn't do
what they spent their time doing what
they exposed their son to is absolutely
material informative under 401 and
pursuant to people versus males
there is no duty owed to community
members from just every person in public
so
i don't believe that's a proper
response but more importantly there is
no duty to a community
duty owed to a community that the
prosecutor
argues exists
in terms of the the question itself
whether or not there was some type of
extramarital relationship between
the parties and the duty to the
community
i don't know that that is intertwined
however as far as the relevancy goes to
the ultimate issue of this particular
case i'm overwhelming the objection you
can go ahead and answer a question thank
you
could you repeat the question yes just
one moment
if you just want to just for to make a
good record um
my
the duty over here is is to protect the
community from
uh intentionally
there's unintentionally harming somebody
when they knew he was preoccupied with
violent material that they he had access
to a gun he could use it when he wanted
to and he was disturbed it's a parental
duty it goes far beyond careless it's
gross negligence and there's absolutely
a duty and i didn't get a chance to tie
that together but i'll move on
what
what was the indicator to you that there
was an another um
relationship going on outside her
outside
jennifer crumley's marriage she spoke to
me about it
okay did you notice anything um prior to
that
i didn't notice anything though okay
what did she say
she had told me that she had been seeing
somebody else
did she tell you
who that person was no
and did she tell you when she saw that
person
um
one time
okay
tell me about that um
there was a point where um
i had noticed that she was there in the
morning and she had mentioned that she
had seen a man um
in the morning before during work hours
what do you mean you noticed she wasn't
there
was it before she was supposed to come
into her um i typically got in after her
um i would notice that she
had been there her light was on and
everything but she was not there
um and it would be about an hour until
she ever seen her after work did you ask
her about that or did she just i didn't
ask but she had mentioned you know
errands at first and then um she had
mentioned about a week after that it was
she seeing somebody else and where
where would she did she say where she
would go during those hours
um she said that
this person would pick her up and they
would go across the street from our
office
to where
did she say what they were doing
um not directly no okay
and um did
the uh
did
what did jennifer say about what result
did she talk about her son gary
uh no not very often what did she think
about other than her marital issues
a lot of it was about the horses um
she talked about she purchased a new
horse just kidding
um and then a lot of people
okay i'm sorry so i didn't catch that
last time she was she would talk about a
lot of um yard work and housework she
was doing her door
did she say whether or not her son was
aware of these marital issues
um
not directly no um he would overhear
fights occasionally but i i don't know
if we've heard anything else okay thank
you do you follow jennifer crumbly on
social media
we're friends on facebook yes okay and
did you ever see a post about
um their son and how they bought their
their son and done before christmas
early christmas present i didn't see
did she ever talk to you about funds no
okay
do you have a suspicion about why she
didn't mention that she's mentioning all
the
do you know why
no okay um
what uh
you did at some point get an opportunity
to
look at the post
yeah okay and when was that
on the day on november 30th okay so
let's let's go to november 29th the day
before
um this
uh terrible um event occurred
did you see jennifer on november 29th
yeah
and
at some point was there anything unusual
that occurred that day
um she mentioned that she got a message
from school
um but she didn't go or
did she say what the message was no did
she seem concerned in any way
no
what
how would you describe her
uh normal calm
did she say what she was going to do
um
with regard to that message or what
she's going to do
no
okay
and
did she say did she mention anything
about how what her son was doing
recently around that time
no
okay
did she did uh jennifer uh probably ever
talk to you about what
how she described her son
um
[Music]
um only when his friends had gone away
um that was the only time
okay and did she say specifically what
concerned her about his friend going
away
she was concerned he would be lonely um
that it was
his only being friends maybe only
friends
okay and particularly did she say when
she was concerned that he would be alone
no no
okay how often did jennifer and james
probably go to the farm
[Music]
did jennifer talk to you about um going
to the bar yeah um how often did she
talk to you about going to the barn
almost failing all right so was that in
the context of she's just bringing it up
or she's talking about her plans after
work um
about how often did she go
failing okay and did ethan go with her
not to my knowledge did she ever express
a concern about
her son not going with her
no
okay
the next day
november 30th do you remember that day
yes okay what's the first time that you
um talk to jennifer and remember
in the morning i went in
drink coffee and on my way back to my
desk i
stopped briefly is that something that
you would
nearly do yeah okay and
at some point um
did
did you become aware of
a call about her son yeah how did you
become aware um
[Music]
um this was later in the day the first
call was from um the school okay um
that there was an issue at the school
um
okay what did she do after that
she called her and what did she tell
james um
did she say now she felt about going to
school
no
okay did she say whether she wanted to
go or didn't want to go
no
okay
um did was she trying to ask james to go
instead of her or they were to come too
it sounded like she wanted james to go
um and then um there was
did she come back to work yeah
all right um when she came back to work
what did she tell you
um she came over to my desk um she
showed me she said
that she felt like a failure as a parent
and she showed me a photo of um what
anything's drawn at school okay that was
previously um
admitted uh do you need to see it to
describe it or do you remember the
photo um i remember the photo okay what
what um
how would you describe
the writings on the
um
disturbing
okay and what was your response
i told her i thought that was gary
i'm sorry you said what i told her i
thought it was scary okay
and what was her response she agreed
okay
did
did she talk to you at all about what
the meeting
um was about or what the school wanted
her to do yeah what did she say
she said that um
that they were concerned with his
drawing that they were concerned that he
may be feeling
badly at fool and that something could
happen
um she said that they were
requiring her to do um engaging
counseling and that you needed to do
that quickly
um
did you start i didn't know your last
part
okay
did what was your demeanor when she was
talking to you about this
um my initial
thought was it seemed a little sarcastic
the way that she said that she felt like
a feeling um as she was talking it was a
little concerned um
okay did you have a conversation at some
point about whether or not she should go
and get her son from school
um i thought
i would have brought him home
did you have a um about that yeah tell
me what was what did you say i said um
it would be nice for her to take him for
a day to you know
go see a movie or go have lunch or do
something with him on that day yes on
that day um
i said she should have brought them home
and why did you say that
i felt it was
a disturbing photo and i thought
i needed to be around family um
okay what was her response
um she told me that she thought she
would just take him to the barn that
night and you know give him some work
and give him a little something to do
after school
and what did you say to that
i said
but she thought um would be good for him
what did you say
um
all right um
at some point you
what what happened what was the next
thing you can remember on that day
um after that conversation she went back
from her office i went back to work
and
a little while after i don't remember
all the time
she had received a call and i believe it
was from gaines that he got an alert
from the school about an active shooter
um and she started to panic in her
office
and i think we all did hearing the fall
and that's when she she
left
right away okay um
did you
you said that at one point
she told you that she and james
separated but
didn't really
um
move out
and then you said at some point they got
back together
do you know when that was or no
oh i'm sorry you have to say yes or no
yeah okay do you know when that was or
how do you know that um
she had mentioned that they were having
the issues um she they decided to
separate um quite early it seemed um and
then around their anniversary they she
came back from a trip with him and then
she said that they were going to work on
it and one
was that what was that in the fall i
don't recall okay and where was the trip
um i i don't know
but i don't know which one
did she tell you whether or not
they took their son along for the
weekend to the casino no
no she didn't tell you or no they didn't
take them no she didn't tell me okay you
know if they took him
i don't know okay
um
did you ever hear
uh
jennifer talked to to you or say in
passing that she was taking ethan to the
doctor
no
to the therapist no
um did she ever talk to you about the
horses needing medical
treatment yes
what would she say
um there was some i don't remember
exactly what was wrong with them
did that happen
once more than once more than once
thank you
[Music]
hello
um i want to go back through some of
your testimony and just make sure that
i've understood it correctly so if i say
something wrong can you please let me
know yeah
um you were the administrative assistant
to andy smith is that correct yeah so
you worked in the same office jennifer
crumbly worked out of
yeah the same company i'm sorry the same
the same company the same company
and your um
desk was nearby miss miss crumbly's
office yeah
and you and miss crumbly you would not
say you were friends with one another
correct
but you
talked about
little things back and forth when you
would see each other yeah always
friendly conversation
yeah
and
uh
i imagine over time you talked about a
number of different topics correct yes
so when you're talking about the topics
today um
being
their marriage and
um
separating and things like that it's
fair to say there were topics discussed
lots of other topics that have not been
pinpointed today correct
yes there were discussions about camping
trips the family talk
yes um conversations about james's
mother dying
um conversations about
um
meals jennifer was cooking
no
conversations about the pictures that
were up on facebook
i saw one photo
i guess my point is there were
conversations about lots of different
topics it was not like only about
jennifer's marriage did you two speak
correct right
and
in terms of jennifer's marriage and what
you were told
it's fair to say that jennifer didn't
sit down with you and give you a play by
play on everything that was happening
within her marriage correct
it's more like uh you would catch bits
of it here and there correct
she went into detail about certain
issues so there's conversations you had
where she went into detail
but it does say there were other times
where you would hear her on the phone
with james yes um it's fair to say that
other people in the office may have been
talking about jennifer and james
no
it's it's fair to say that
although jennifer did tell you things um
this was not like a daily event where
you sat down and discussed every
intricacy of her marriage correct right
so there was certainly a time where
jennifer and james um
your understanding was that they were
going to get separated or separated
yes and there was discussion about
jennifer possibly seeing somebody else
at that time
you don't know all the details about
seeing someone else
no no
and the the most you knew is that during
work hours jennifer
uh would not be at her desk correct
uh that's not all i knew but
yes i did know that
you testified that um you would notice
her light would be on as if she had been
at her desk and then she would be gone
from the building is that correct
and that you were told uh by jennifer
she was running errands at some point in
time yes and specifically
you were told at some point that she had
gone to costco with another person yes
and
anytime that you were aware
um
[Music]
of her being gone
these times that you're talking about
those were all within the workday is
that correct
yes
so you testified that
um there was a day
that jennifer got a message from the
school is that correct
yes and that message from the school was
a voicemail
i don't know i know
did you hear the message no do you know
anything about what the message said no
uh did jennifer
tell you the contents of the message no
did jennifer tell you how she felt about
the message
no
what do you
is there do you know anything about the
message
so you don't know the contents of the
message no
so you would have no ability to evaluate
whether how jennifer was reacting in
conjunction with that message correct
the message on this one tonight yes i
don't know okay
so when you testified that um
jennifer did not seem concerned it's
fair to say you don't even know what the
message on the 29th was about correct
right
and jennifer
expressed to you that a message had been
left by the school
yes
and it's fair to say that you had never
jennifer had never told you that at any
time before correct
like before that day yeah
no that was the first passage i knew
about the present school from the 29th
okay so when she got the message from
the 29th and mentioned it to you that
was certainly out of the ordinary
correct
yeah and jennifer um telling you about
it appeared she cared that she had
gotten the message from the school
i don't know
um your understanding of ethan was that
he was a quieter kid is that correct yes
and that he had a friend who had moved
away suddenly so he was lonely
um
you were aware that he
were you aware that he had a difficult
time when his uh grandmother died
no
were you aware of ethan's
extracurricular activities no
were you aware when ethan was going to
become a referee for the soccer team no
um were you aware of
um
summer classes that you then took no
your um your knowledge you never met
anything in person
and
you so really your knowledge about ethan
is very limited from what you heard from
his mother is that correct yeah and
ethan was not on something or someone
she talked about uh with you at the
office frequently correct
when you testified that
jennifer
was at the barn daily
um
is that your perception of what she was
doing or do you have actual knowledge
that she went to the barn every day
i it was almost every day that she would
tell me she was going after her
almost every day yes
and so based on the fact that
um she went to the barn frequently um
did you have any other awareness of what
she was doing at night or
on weekends things like that
um
no
through her facebook page would you see
the camping trips and family trips they
took
okay yes
okay so you were aware that um
we have we do not dispute it jennifer
loves horses correct
and uh she would post pictures from the
horse the horses in the farm
pictures of her
family
camping and on vacation
um you testified that you saw the
picture of the targets that were shot um
that were posted on facebook correct
on november uh 30th
you testified that
you spoke to jennifer briefly when she
came in is that right
and
that you could hear a phone call from
james about a school shooter is that
correct yeah was that the first um thing
on your radar
about something going on at the oxford
high school
um at the school in general or with even
um either so at the school in general
um
that was the first time i was in school
but i thanked her to call it
okay but that was the first you were
aware that there was a
shooting or a
larger scale incident at oxford yes
um at what point did you see the um
photograph of the drawing ethan made in
the on the map paperwork
when did i see it first yeah unless she
returned from the um
when she returned from the meeting at
the school so that was the day before
correct no i saw the photo on the 30th
you saw the photo on the 30th yes okay
and
um
when you
uh you testified that you found it to be
um disturbing and scary correct
uh jennifer was also seemed concerned
about that drawing on that mac paperwork
correct
yes um she
she was talking about whether or not he
would stay at school or if he was coming
home that day correct
no
she well she ultimately told you that
they they left him at school that day
you're aware of that correct yes
did you have conversations with jennifer
about why they left him at school yeah
were you aware that the school told
jennifer he was of no threat to anyone
objection in your honor that is not a
fact
were you aware did jennifer say anything
that the school told jennifer he is not
a threat to anyone
no
did jennifer tell you
um
any concerns about ethan staying home
from school versus going because of how
the zoom school year had gone the year
before
did jennifer um tell you anything about
having the option to take him from
school or leave him at school
now
as you testified that you would have
taken him home as your son is that
correct yeah do you have children
yes how old are your children
young
under 15 yeah how old
are you
i don't know how this is relevant and
it's clear she's not comfortable
answering these questions given
the amount of attention the case is
getting so i would just ask if we could
just
i don't know why she doesn't need to
know
your honor she was allowed to give
opinions about what a mother would do
i'm direct i think this is a fair
question background question i would ask
the media not to put this out there this
is not
she didn't give an opinion about what a
mother would do she gave an opinion
about what she would do so i don't know
why we then have to ask her about her
personal life
i don't know how the age and number and
gender irrelevancy is to the age of the
child
the prosecution opened the doors to her
giving an opinion about a child whether
they should be taken home from school or
not she testified that as a mother she
would have taken the child home i'm
asking her as a mother how old her child
is
range
arranged okay
thank you can we have an age range
please for your son
okay so not anywhere near a teenager
not even like a middle schooler right
and the day that
you saw jennifer when when you say you
would have taken him home you didn't say
to jennifer you should have taken him
home correct
no you didn't call the police and say i
just saw a very alarming drawing and
this mother did not take her child home
from school correct
you didn't call the school and say hey
i'm concerned because i just saw this
drawing and mother seems to not not be
worried about it correct
you as a matter of fact you didn't do
anything after seeing that drawing with
respect to the drawing correct
i told her i would have taken my son
home that's all you did though yeah
and now looking at the situation
um you have a greater awareness
based on hindsight 20 20 vision correct
some of the things that you're
testifying about
you would agree with me you know more
information now than you did at the time
when you were having conversations with
jennifer crumbly correct
about this case yes yes
you had no idea school shooting was
going to take place based on seeing that
drawing from that map paper correct
you did not
voice to anyone after seeing that
drawing on the map paperwork
there could be a school shooting correct
i think the gun was alarming i think
that if i thought about it now i think
correct i don't think i fulfill it so
you would agree with me that you look at
things differently in hindsight when you
look back
you look at things differently correct
when jennifer um did talk to you on the
day of the school shooting
she said that the school wanted ethan in
counseling correct yes she did not tell
you she wasn't going to get him in
counseling
correct you can just
she didn't say anything um to indicate
to you then that she wasn't going to
follow the school's
counseling idea correct
she said to you that she felt like a
failure
is that a fair statement yes
and we can agree that jennifer can have
a sarcastic personality at times
and when she said something like i feel
like such a failure
um
it's possible that some of that was
sarcasm correct yes
jennifer did say that night she was
going to take ethan to the barn with her
correct yes she did say she did not want
him to be alone correct
i'm sorry no
did she say she
did she say anything about him being
alone
no not that day
did she talk to you about who he would
have been with had he left school that
day no
as far as you knew it jennifer's plan
after work that day was to get ethan and
take him to the barn correct yes and
jennifer said she was doing that whether
or not even wanted to correct
she was concerned about being with ethan
after school
i don't know
she was planning to be with ethan after
school
[Music]
when the alert came in about the school
shooting um you would agree jennifer was
panicking
yeah
and she you testified that she ran out
of the school quickly
and she appeared upset that she was
running out of the building
and leaving is that correct
and i imagine that everyone in your
office
was nervous and anxious about what was
unfolding is that correct yes
and it was something that all of you
were talking about
um especially because jennifer was
running out the door
and her son went to that high school is
that correct
yes
it's also fair to say that after you
after jennifer did leave that day
um
you sent
you sent her a message
is that correct
and your message was intended to be kind
and intended to be supportive
yes
and you
you pretty much said something along the
lines of thinking of you guys correct
yes
and also that you hope her and her
family were doing all right yes that was
before you knew um exactly what had
unfolded correct right
i have no further questions
any questions on behalf of james none
for mr crumley or any redraw
and it was a romantic relationship
correct
and you asked her or she told you she
saw this person during work hours in the
parking lot possible
right yeah oh thank you
president council just asked you a lot
of questions about what you knew and
what you didn't know and if your your
[Music]
um
did you know that
they bought their son a gun and gave him
access to it no i'm judging your honor
did you know
did you
what was the objection
it's an improper question and the
prosecutor repeatedly keeps asking
questions that are are designed to
inflame the public and make everyone
believe there is access to the gun that
has not been testified to
it's not true
and these questions are by design to try
to have these people convicted in the
media that question is improper it's
also assuming facts not in evidence and
facts that will never be in evidence
your honor and if you recall the
objective previously with another
witness and you sustain the objection
using almost identical language
i i've asked those questions refrain
from the the asking the question
relative to access of our sustained
objection okay
did you know that the the gun in the
congolese possession was identical to
the drawing um that their son made on
the math orgy no
did you know that the day before
jennifer crumbly texted her son lol just
you have to learn not to get caught when
he was in trouble for searching
ammunition no did you know that james
crumbly upon hearing there was a school
shooting went to the house to look for
the bun
no okay did you know we called 9-1-1
then and said that i think my son is a
school shooter no okay did you know how
many hours
and hours that ethan probably the
shooter spent at his house by himself
objection
again
question with no foundation
with an absolutely no phone
my point is there was a lot you didn't
know correct correct but just what you
knew not as his parents not what he did
not any of the other things you were
alarmed and concerned when you saw that
worksheet right yes
no objection not from mr crumbly rather
i need prosecutors
okay we're going to take a quick break
it'll be one minute we're just taking a
quick break
what were some of your previous
assignments i worked dispatch uh signed
corrections roll patrol
sir if you could please tell us what a
uh detective in the oakland county
sheriff's office computer crimes would
be
cell phones computers do friendly
examinations
er systems
now in your 25 years experience with the
sheriff's office if you have the
opportunity to participate in specific
trainings with regards to forensic
analysis of computer consultants yes sir
sensor could you tell us a little bit
about that uh the main one that we
attended is an international
certification uh isis and you have to
review that every year there's a seven
month testing process for that
celebrate is some of the software we use
uh there's training for that i've been
to a certified user for that axiom
software
now sir i imagine that in this
particular field technology is always
changing yes sir would it be fair to say
then that your training is also
ongoing every year yes
and so if you provide us with your cv
my my account we have 30 training
specific cell phone houses that sound
all right yes sir
every time you get
yes sir
in your seven years working with the
oakland county sheriff's office computer
crimes you've had the opportunity to
conduct data extractions
yes sir
is this something you do on a regular
basis almost every day would you give a
put a number how many times you've
actually done a data extraction itself
well over 500
tell us how
this process is how that works
so if a phone is brought in by the
detective in charge of the case they
bring it in we hook it up there's a
software that we have a device that you
fed touches made by celebrate hook it up
to that device
it tracks the data off of it and we use
software you've got physical analyzer
usually to examine
the data that was just obtained from the
device
now this is celebrating this is
software correct celebrating the company
it's your company i'm very physical
analyze yourself okay and after you
review the data on that
yes sir is that typically done in the
pdf form usually yes
you're going to qualify as an expert
yes sir in which course
uh sixth search report
if
so six report that is the entire oakland
county circuit court am i right yes sir
so is it more than one judgment you
multiply your next professor
what field you can qualify
um i do just want to make one thing here
you were told that the mapping
um
would not be testified to and that's
some of the information you didn't
receive i just want to make sure we're
on track with that no that's correct
we're not going to explore the call
detail record math
he just has to find that his experience
he's done it
okay the court will go ahead and qualify
him
no objection for mr crumbly either
sir i would like to direct your
attention to november the 30th 2021. do
you remember today yes sir reworking yes
sir
remain aware of the school shooting at
oxford high school yes sir
tell us what you did
i
got prepared i was notified by our
captain that there was a shooting in
oxford and everybody had to go and i got
equipment that you would need to deal
with a situation like that what sort of
equipment
body armor um duty rifle stuff like that
so this is you detecting computer crimes
you were still obtaining this over here
yes sir
did you actually go to the high school
at first i went to the minors and then i
went to high school and there's a meyer
jason in high school am i right yes sir
there's a lot of radio tracking i've
been
here staging area and um garden center
for the meyer and stuff like that so
when i got up there i wasn't entirely
familiar with the area i'm not from that
area so i saw the wire that's where i
went first okay at some point while
you're around the meyer were you
requested to report to the oxford high
school office yes sir did you do so yes
sir what was the purpose for you being
cast there to help get the dvr video
footage of school
did somebody from the school assist you
with that yes sir who's that jim
what is the rule there you know he's uh
part of their security
private security
so in your role as a detective with
computer crimes unit um
you were asked to obtain and review the
footage am i right yes sir did you
actually review the footage of the
shooting november
yes sir
were you also requested to repeat it
from other cars that did yes sir
in fact did you eventually obtain the
entire server principle yes
sir
i was a member of the oakland county
sheriff's office computer crimes unit do
you work hand in hand with other
detectives
so this is probably especially true in
the case of this
now in this case
we're phones cell phones he's from
james jennifer
yes sir
and those receipts pursuant search
warrant yes sir
now in addition to
the oxford high school surveillance
system did you also obtain
surveillance footage from
requirements yes sir okay and what did
you do with that
i uh because the way the video system is
broken up in a 16 different cameras so i
was able to take clips of the day that
were of interest and stream all together
okay
now during the course of this
investigation
did you become aware that james crumbley
was employed at the door
yes sir and was the search warrant
executed on the company your dash to
obtain records from that yes sir did you
review those as well yes sir
was information obtained from social
media outlets it was worked for as well
yes sir does that include instagram and
facebook yes sir
now sir is it true that even if another
detective actually authored the search
warrant
when they return when the information is
received it's a detective like yourself
or computer requirements that actually
goes through that information yes sir
in this case you have the opportunity to
review the data extractions from
james crumbly's cell phone jennifer
crumbling cell phone if you can find
yourself yes sir
did you use the celebrate program that
we talked about
now tell us the fact that someone were
to actually
deactivate their social media accounts
which uses investigators to hope to
obtain that information from the device
itself yes sir they tell me why
you would
it would still be on the device even
though they
deactivated activated encounter the
databases that the information is stored
in that we're able to look at those and
then see the text for the conversation
as well back and forth in the databases
delete the third time
that's different because then
you're telling the phone that it's not
of interest
could you as an investigator in this
field still hope to obtain that data
sometimes yes sir tell me how wait the
devices or the software you use actually
does it call carving for data and it
looks deeper into the
information that was obtained and tried
to extract those databases even though
they're broken up would be some kind of
perfect okay now if you were concerned
that someone were going to delete
international let's say facebook or
instagram account how would you an
investigator try to convince all that
data or you would serve a preservation
letter what does that mean
it gives an investigator 90 days to get
a search warrant and it's served on the
company whether it's facebook tick tock
whatever and it just tells them this
account don't do anything with it even
if the user says i don't want any more
just save it as it is right now and work
preservation
particularly now in addition to the data
extractions and the cell phones
themselves did you have the opportunity
to review search warrant returns from
ethan crumbley's instagram account yes
sir about jennifer crumley's instagram
yes sir
james crumby's instagram no yes sir
jennifer probably facebook account
yes sir
and uh james crumbley's door ditch
account yes sir and also james cronin's
facebook yes
they give the police their phone numbers
yes sir okay then where did the police
also become known you can become known
from this one
yes yes sir all right so what i'm asking
you is when you have a cell phone it's
given to you you don't know who's it is
right away am i correct correct okay now
is there a way for you when you review
the data extraction to tie in
cell phone device to the owner of a cell
phone yes sir how is that but usually
the evidence bank that comes in is
marked as whoever phone it was but it's
also verified by when we extract the
data from the phone the phone number is
saved in the phone usually on the sim
card
yes sir okay is this information
available on the data extractions of
ethanol cell phone yes sir and also the
defendant jennifer found himself correct
okay
also how many devices were recovered
from jennifer
jennifer
four total cell phones that were
recovered
tell me how that happened the first one
that the search warrant served at their
house um after the shooting um and their
phone receives them
then we discovered that through the
investigation that they went and
purchased the exact same cell phones and
then also um two phones two track phones
and what's the track from it's
we refer it as a burner phone it's a
pre-paid performance you get from
walmart or player
we say three we're talking about the
original the same phone user versus in
the backbone yes sir
and what about ethan
just one
throughout the course of this direct
examination i am going to be referring
only to your original cell phone the
phone that receives in the data search
unless i specifically standardized so
we're clear okay
now as part of your gate extraction
jennifer currently cell phone did you
review audio recordings yes sir do you
have occasion to
identify an audio recording of the
stages of voicing on november 29 2021.
yes sir
so she says people supposed
okay there's a stipulation is to build
attorneys correct
high school and i'm here with
introductions to ethan's counselor i was
just calling just let you know that we
just spoke with evan had a really nice
conversation um one of his teachers
had sent an email to the office just
that she was concerned because um ethan
when she was walking around the room
checking assignments but he was on his
phone looking at
bullets um and that sort of thing so she
just wanted us to have a conversation we
did he said he assessed the shooting
range with you this weekend and we were
like yep you know uh
you know guns are a hobby for a lot of
people and shooting ranges and that's
perfectly normal
um and that we just wanted to make sure
i
had a conversation with him about
the things he searches at school
um things versus searching and searching
at home like with your husband's give a
good example of like if a teacher makes
beer
um at home perfectly normal and healthy
but can't be using searches for making
beer at school so we had a conversation
he was he was great and he said yes i
get it so i just wanted to let you know
that we did have a conversation with him
and
um
i don't know about five minutes and he
went back to class all right if you have
any questions you can give me a call at
248-572-9565-248-572-9565
that was the complete recording from the
phone all right yes sir
now you testified that you reviewed the
data extractions on both ethan and
jennifer
yes sir
yes sir
did you export that to a pdf yes sir
when you review a data extraction
on celebrate you were able to put it in
searchable searchable format yes okay
tell me how that works but there's
within the different tabs either whether
it's a text message or call logs or
whatever there's a search field type in
whether it's a phone number a name a
keyword or whatever put it in there and
it just narrows down the search of the
information of what you're looking for
okay thank you
now sir this entire text spreads 293
pages with about 1150 messages is that
right
i'm sorry can the prosecutor repeat that
and slow down i can't hear
i can't hear him yeah if you could i'm
sorry just slow down a little bit and
then we can hear the full question
thanks george absolutely
yes sir okay
so i just proposed exhibit 10. i do not
believe we have an objection this is
page 286 to 291 for the record we do
have a thumb drive for the court as well
as defense counsel with the entire
exported text thread but this exhibit is
page 286
so the exhibit itself is a portion of
the thumb drive okay any objections to
the admissibility of the exhibit 10.
um actually yes the
exhibit that was given to me actually
goes through page
293.
right
but
you said
293 that's right okay 286 through 293 is
what i know okay no you're right i said
290 i'm sorry
he said it two pages shorter so i was i
just want to make sure we go all the way
through 293. we're correct we're right
all right so for purposes of uh
admissibility for those documents any
objections that being pages 286 through
293 of the text messages
do you recognize that sir yes sir and
how do you recognize that it's an export
of a pdf format uh
but it's published on the screen
now the top um
the top right is a green text bubble is
that right yes sir okay this is on page
286 that i've identified and what does
it say at the top there
uh the sentence well first of all does
it identify owner
it doesn't identify the owner and says
who it's two okay but this was taken off
of jennifer crumley's phone
all right and who does it say this
uh ethan is that the phone number
provided for ethan crumbly yes sir okay
so this message was sent to ethan
crumbly from jennifer public according
to your analysis correct and what's the
first message
seriously question mark question mark
looking up bullets in school question
mark question mark and what time and
date was that set that's on the 29th of
november 2021 at 11 53 am
what was the response
he responded
almost nearly answered by saying what
okay was there a second and third
response yeah he responded saying oh
yeah
i already went to the office for that
and then this is page
287 the top this is the blue text bubble
what does it say
it was in first hour all i did was look
up a certain caliber at the end of class
because i was curious and what time is
that
that's at 11 54.
next textbook
he's saying it was on my phone
completely harmless teachers just had no
privacy
and the first text
from
ethan crumley to jennifer
they said i'm all good
i understand why
i they talked to me and they said that
they that is i'm good okay and you're
ready reading this exactly how it's
examined
this is nothing i should get in trouble
about okay what what time is that son
that was at 11 55 also on november 29th
and 2020 yes sir all right
and there was a response there from
jennifer crumbly
yes
she responded with you're not they left
me a voicemail
and then there's emojis after it with
hand over face
and what time of date was that at 12 13
um
at 11 29.
sir what does this text hear the green
bubbles sent from jennifer cromwell to
ethan crumbly said
on the next page yes sir it says did you
at least show them a pic of your new gun
what time did you write that at 12 13 12
14. yeah on november 29th as well yes
sir
what was his response oh i didn't show
them the pic my god
next
i only told them i went to the rank with
you on saturday it was a harmless hat
okay now we're on page 290 the first
text from ethan crumley to jennifer from
i had this boy cartridge in my room that
i didn't
what kind of bullet it was
and it said it was a 22 so at the end of
first hour i just looked up different
types of 22 bullets and i guess the
teachers can't get their eyes off my
screen smh what does that
and what was jennifer herman's response
to that
lol
i'm not mad
you have to learn not to get caught
are there periods in between some of
these words
yes in between uh i'm not in the
beginning of a sentence and in between
the three words of not give caught
what time does she write right you have
to learn not to get caught
that was at 12 31 on november 29 yes sir
and his response to that
ik lol
was there a power response
he had uh those appears to be lacking
emojis
i just didn't want something this little
to get me in trouble because well i
didn't want to get in trouble hello
and yeah another text
you see i want to hear the voicemail
when i get home though
also i never tried to hide we looked up
the bullet i just didn't think a teacher
would be staring at my phone
did she respond to that she did she
generally responded okay i saved it
and correctly wrong but those are the
text messages from november the 29th is
that right correct okay we'll come back
to this exhibit a little bit
may i approach it with this job yes
in fact if you told us that you had the
opportunity to review data received from
kingston is that right yes sir okay
did that include uh ethan jennifer and
james accounts yes sir
do you know what jennifer crumley's
instagram user
it was identified as
gen c
78 j ehn c78 okay and we're able to find
that on the device as well yes sir
when you're able to locate that
information on the device are you going
to export that to the pdf yes sir
this is people's proposal 11.
so what is that that i just handed you
it's a pdf report from uh visual
analyzer software in with the change it
is uh user accounts is the report itself
and it's the username of gen cjhnc78
for instagram and so that's how you're
going to verify what jennifer crumbley's
instagram user name yes people move to
midnight
any objection no objection come from mr
grumbling admitted
to publish this
report
all right so this is the page that i
hand you
yes sir okay so under user account let
me talk about user accounts earlier so
under user accounts here we have a
username
yes sir and this is where we have jeh78
as well yes sir and you recall what his
username was his was his name james
crumbly
54321
did you do the same process with the
user accounts
on james crumbly's actual device to
verify that yes sir they approached it
yes this is people's proposed 12.
sir what am i handing you there's a pdf
report from
analyzer software is did you hand in the
same method did you obtain the
information for jennifer
yes sir people move them in number 12.
none from mr crumbly
probably no objection thank you i'll be
admitted
sir on the screen here this appears to
be the same type of pdf is that right
yes sir okay but this is from james
crumley and you know that comes user
account information yes sir and his
username james
five four three two one which you've
identified earlier right thank you
now referring first to the
instagram returns
[Music]
the other one was even crumbly period
and then ethan underscore probably
i want to talk to you just right now
about the ethan dot criminal accounts
for pictures and first of all did you
receive information from instagram on
that account did you have the
opportunity to review that yes sir all
right
were pictures and posts made on their
account yes sir
now i'm going to show you
this is people's
13.
that's for the ethan.permanently account
yes sir and that exhibit proposed
exhibit has a number of pages that
correct
yes sir okay and is that the information
that you actually received and reviewed
from the ethern.com
there's no objection to the photo photo
part of it being admitted but there's
some text afterwards that i don't feel
hey i don't think it's relevant
i suppose i can ask the witness about it
on cross-examination
according to
my documents exhibit 13 is
several pages correct yes sir
um
how many pages do you know 16 17
17 pages do you have all 17 pages
17 pages
i do have 17 pages um i
if i could just ask the prosecutor very
quickly
okay i have no objection thank you okay
any objection down here but james trump
not from mr cumberland okay exhibit 13
will be admitted
and just for clarification this is for
just the even probably account
ethan.crumbling yes josh that's it
now are you able to tell when you look
at the instagram returns what time
something is posted in time yes sir okay
so this first one page one here
we have an image is that right yes sir
okay this image appears to be a
target for holes in it correct all right
let me make sure the same one we have a
taken
date and time do you see that as well
yes sir what is the taken date
taking date time is 11 27 2021 at 1902
utc and when you see utc without a minus
next to what is that
it's just as the time that grinch
meantime where all time starts and
depending on how far you are away from
grunge meantime you lose an hour gain an
hour and currently we're at minus five
okay so this picture actually posted
1900 hours
at a different tension and what time is
it
sorry
i'm sorry you said it was posted at 1402
yes ma'am
taking
instagram logs all their stuff at utc
time so the utc was not a 702 or 1902
but since we're at -5 right now it's
1402 active when it was taken and posted
thank you
was there a text associated with this
photograph as well yes sir i'm not going
to ask you about the other comments that
have been posted
after november the 27th
just the comments posted by the user
so page two
at the top we have a text area yes sir
what does that say
it's i took my new sig up to the range
today definitely need to get used to the
new sites lol okay now that was posted
by the user and we've identified that as
ethan cromwell is that right correct
scroll through to the next photograph
this is the third page of what i've
handed you
insert this photographic little firearm
on the same page yes sir all right and
does it have a date and time taken
yes sir and what day does that
1126 2021 at 1806 utc or 306. okay so
the target was taken november 27th so
the picture of this firearm is taking
november the 26th correct
and do we have a text associated with
user of this account yes sir what is
that just got my new beauty today with
heart eyes emoji
six hour nine millimeter ask any
questions i will answer
okay now to the following page we have
another photograph this is also a
firearm yes sir all right and what is
the date and time on this
89 11 26 2021
and 1806 utc or 306 okay
and that was about the same time the
other photographer posted as well right
right
and we have a text box with the user and
it's the same text just got my new
beauty today with the hard eyes moving
correct
the following page page five here what
are we looking at
a picture of someone holding a handgun
whiteboards are before
and this was a um we have a date time
when this was taken in public yes sir
what is that 11 26 2021 at 1806 utc for
306 permission okay and again the same
text just got my new beauty today with
her and eyes looking correct
so when we have the same date and time
with uh multiple photographs that we
have here to assume that he's a
yes sir
give a chance to review some of the
other photographs on this account
yesterday
i'm going to scroll
through these this is h6
h7 you found that one as well yes sir
i'm sorry
we know for sure that the firearms were
posted on by the user using chrome what
about these other photographs were they
posted by ethan crumbly or they just
shared on his account
okay first of all let's identify what
photographs you're talking about thank
you jose i appreciate that this is we're
starting with what's on page six with
the photographic speech publisher
the question is whether it's shared
versus posted by you correctly
all right i'm gonna move back down to
where page seven we've already do this
one
these easily stopped
page 9
10
15
and the last one is
your honor at this point um
i would i
stipulate to pages one through five
coming in as ethan's account but it's
very clear that six through 17 are other
user names throughout the pictures
if you don't mind as far as further
response judges our next exhibit
is a contact page about james and
jennifer's device of the show they
followed
that problem
but as it relates to the pages of
photographs that's being pages
6 through
16.
please clarify with the wit with the
witness
who actually posted those photographs
again i don't mind clarifying the
detective however our position is
[Music]
just by virtue of the information that's
provided on the exhibit
mountains
um
and if you look at the text underneath
the photograph
it has two usernames there
can you tell the report what the
significance is of those usernames on
that particular page those appear to be
state commented on the picture
one says the text is tf the other one
text says so true okay thank you
are you going to tell us about in this
exhibition
looking at
i'm looking at the
upload ids
so the upload the ip address that was
used to upload
the
photos of the firearm that had text that
we know ethan
made is different but yet a little
similar without double checking being
able to check the ip addresses of all
the uploads i couldn't tell you right
now for certain but the fact that one
has comments after it would lead me to
believe that that was mostly
page six yes ma'am
your honor we i mean we can explore this
more on cross-examination but
these are very different circumstances
this has user names listed that are not
ethan crumbling so we object again to
pages six through seventeen coming in
um detective on
[Music]
on pages one through five where photos
are
we're talking about the picture of the
target
and then there's a picture of a gun in a
case
and a picture of ethan holding a gun
presumably and then a picture of you
then pointing the gun down
those
those five pages
after each of those pictures
you can see that it says comments user
ethan.crumbly correct yes
okay
on page six
there's a different photograph of like
this ghost face
and in the same spot where it says ethan
dot crumbly it says user augusto ferrari
zero two two seven
yes ma'am okay so
augusto ferrari is
and there is nothing on here
showing
ethan.crumbling's name correct on page
six ma'am yes
and
but on pages one through five ethan dot
crumbly
is on all of those photographs
that's right
okay
so
the photograph with the white face um
the second page that looks like it's
kind of that same white face page seven
of 17 again nowhere on there does that
say ethan dot crumbly
and the following page where 8 of 17
again it does not say
ethan that crumbly anywhere
correct
same thing on page uh 9 out of 17.
a little bit i i'm not offering those
photographs to show that you think
crumbly took the photograph they're
offered because they're on his instagram
account okay that's what he means
so as it relates to those photographs
where he incorporates not listed
um how can you identify whether or not
you can converse
okay when you look at the photographs
and you look at the documents is there
anything any reference to his actual
account and if so where is that
to the one starting on page six ma'am
yes there is not starting on page 15 it
does again appear his name even that
crumbly it was the
finger the circle finger like that um
and then also for the very last one on
page 16 his name is also associated with
that your honor on the page 15 and uh 16
that the detective just pointed out
those are like the first couple of
pictures we have hijacked and i
understand i can see the difference
between so the question is for pages 6
through 14
other than what instagram told you
how do you know that that's his account
based on these documents there's no way
to know
unless we were
we probably have to do a couple more
search warrants on an ip address or
something to see where it came from like
that's usually instagram when we ask for
a specific account they give us
everything associated account that we
serve the preservation later on also
so your honor we would object to part
seven uh pages seven through fourteen um
being admitted we have no objection i'm
sorry page five
six six six through 17
actually
six through fourteen
there's no basis for page 15 is fine
page 16 is fine
um
you certainly will have the opportunity
to cross-examine him on that and
the weight of that evidence as it
relates to those pages and the
information that we just gleaned um from
the detector
whether or not we can actually attribute
this to his account
thank
you detectives um if somebody has just a
general course if you have an instagram
account and you post and share
photographs people who follow you
can view those right practice okay now
looking under the devices of james and
jennifer we're
yes
14
uh you could official analyze your
software okay so we're looking at the
next word from jennifer crumley's
contacts regarding instagram right um 14
yes yes sir okay and you obtain that
from the device itself whichever
permanent device itself yes sir
people move to big 14
yeah i would object i don't see it all
where it says it's from jennifer
jennifer's device
man uh detective can you identify
where how you are able to determine that
this is from jennifer's advice when i
was examining the device i went to the
contacts within what i knew to be her
caller which was compared with the phone
number and i escorted it from her
contacts
can i ask the following questions
sir every time you actually hit export
and create a pdf it doesn't actually
list the phone's name use your account
phone number right right right okay so
this is based upon your actual knowledge
your personal knowledge of the phone
data extraction correct
i can't see that from this portion of
the exhibit that they've tendered if you
have you have a testimony so you can
certainly cross-examine them he's
indicated that he was the one that
extracted it um and he is verifying
based upon what he did that this is in
fact the documentation from that
extraction um you will have the
opportunity to cross-examine him on that
for purposes of the disability i'm going
to roll out
conor i would just for the record
joining the objection and i don't know
if we addressed that before but uh mr
cumberland be joining any of the
objections we've raised for mrs
crumblets
14 what's in your hand right now and
this is what the pdf looks like when you
export that information all right
pressure
now you have 15 in front of you sir yes
okay
15 is an export uh from james's james
crumley's cell phone for this context
okay and then it is um james crumly's
instagram contacts as well
correct okay what does that tell you it
says uh has a contact with ethan crumbly
um on instagram and he's following okay
you're probably
done from there that's
[Music]
um it's the same objection but your
honor
it's the same objection um corporal
admitted over objection for the reasons
previously stated on the writer
thank you i might be publishing for the
effective to verify that what i've
published is within
that correct yes sir
sir did you have the opportunity to
review jennifer crumley's instagram
returns yes sir okay now were there
pictures and posts that you were able to
obtain from that instagram return yes
sir
i'm going to approach with
people 16.
there's four pages here sir do you
recognize what i mishanded you yes sir
how do you recognize that it's a search
warrant return a printout or a certain
word from instagram okay and that's on
the jennifer crumbley identifies your
account correct
people move to admit 16.
no objection to 16 for jennifer
uh no objection
that will be admitted
okay again we have
the way the ethern.com this account also
has posts and texts right correct okay
so we have the first page here we have a
photograph
right and i want to make sure we're
looking at the same paragraph what are
you seeing sir i've seen a target
got up here four bullet holes in it
okay
so we have a dating time of the
photograph taken
taken 1127 2021
at 1903 utc or 203 michigan
and we have a text associated with that
photograph yes what's the text
it says mom and sunday testing out his
new access present my first time
shooting a nine millimeter i hit the
bull's eye
second page we have another photograph
yes sir and what do we see here it's a
full back picture of uh
appears to be the same target and the
target doesn't have a name at the top
accurate firearms
we have a date time ticket
taken 11 27 2021 at 1903 utc
so we see a text mom and sunday testing
out his new xmas present my first time
shooting a nine millimeter i hit that i
hate the bulldog that's the same
now we have
another picture here what do we see here
that one is a appears to be a six hour
handgun uh gun case with two magazines
what's underneath the six hour meeting
uh it looks like a pamphlet says atm
youth handgun
act notice
and what time was this taken
this was taken at 11 27 2021 at 1903 utc
or two or three
and what's the text posted by the user
on this account
same as the last one mom is sunday
testing out his new actions present and
first time shooting nine millimeters
when you as an investigator
obtain data from social media returns
like instagram or facebook are you do
you then go through the devices
themselves to
poorly well other activities happening
in the same place in time usually yes or
not not extensively you don't want to go
and go through the whole phone and
change things or possibly delete things
or move things around all right just
look for small key things that i i'm
going to see when i start examining the
phone from the data that was ultimate
so we've already identified the post on
the ethan.permanent account of the
handgun and the text messages associated
with the post about my new viewing that
was taken on november the 26th am i
right right okay did you have a chance
to review the video as time ethan
crumbley's cell phone dated scratch yes
sir
specifically november the 26th 2021 6 39
pm a video post at that time could you
review that yes sir
and you've already had the chance before
today to view that video right right
people
as long as we're going to watch the
video and i can make sure it's one
absolutely admitted that's exhibit 17.
i'm going to play it on the screen here
sir if you could confirm that this is
what you actually found out
[Music]
so was that what she found out that
evening friendly stone in november 26 6
39 p.m yes sir okay now does this
firearm appear to be consistent with the
firearm posted on into that permanently
account yes sir i was also purely
consistent with the firearm posted on
jennifer cronin's
yes sir all right now i'm gonna this is
a 13 seconds clip i'm going to back it
up just a little bit
at uh it's really at the very end the
13th second here
what is this right here that we're
looking at this black rope object that
would be a democracy
is the gun like provided
to
the
purchaser of a handgun typically yes sir
all right and we already talked about
that etf notice i'm going to back this
video up a little bit more
obviously do we see that pamphlet
yes sir okay is that the same apparently
the same atf youth handgun
yes sir
just for the record that was 17.
sir now i want to move on to
facebook returns we will determine the
username of jennifer crumley's facebook
profile yes sir and what was it
jc wrongly okay we're able to determine
the username of james cronkite's
facebook yes sir did you recall that
james r
will be able to extract a facebook
messenger spread between the defendants
between james
yes sir and printed out how many teams
were there
i want to talk specifically about the
pages that the
texas began on
2042 to 2046 so that messes with threats
it's just for the record we've gendered
the entire messenger threat over the
defense that this report has attacked as
well that's marked as exhibit 18.
yesterday
there's no stipulation
stipulation is to both defendants as to
the admissibility of 18 criteria
[Music]
publish on the screen
okay i want to start with november the
30th
yes sir
so we have
uh blue bubble on the left hand side the
first text or facebook message messenger
on message rather on november the 30th
is uh from who
from jc rumbling okay and that's
identified obviously
jennifer crumbly yes sir okay and what
day time was this it was at 11 30 20 21
at 9 33 a.m
if you could read that post with
call now emergency mouse and all cameras
now the second message he sent
the first message
uh
sent after that was just the word
emergency
and what time is that
9 35
am 33 or 9 35 35 am
and what was the next message on the
thread
uh jefferson two photos
okay can we able to tell in your daily
extraction video review what these
photographs were that she said yes sir
what are those photographs it's the the
drawing the math test that
ethan had that he had drawn on
insert
the top
one has already been
the evidence exhibit seven the other one
is going to be exhibit 78.
[Music]
this is a new addition
i have through 77.
the first one is i'll publish to the
fourth one
this has been during the minute of seven
and what am i handing you right now
it's a screenshot that is within the
facts administration okay the first
screenshot of the second screenshot is
up
here should be the first
okay now this is people's proposed 78
certainly recognize that yes sir and how
do you recognize that it's the same
it's a it's a math test a copy of math
test with the certain parts of the
scroll down okay and
that would be the second enhancement set
yes sir
people move to amend 78 on public
support
any objection by uh james crumbling no
objection any objection by jennifer no
judge okay so 78 will be admitted that
is a separate photograph that's going to
be about time
yes
[Music]
and that matches i'm sorry the first or
the second photograph on
facebook posting
i'm going to put 78 on the screen to
make sure that we are all talking about
the same exhibit
so what i'm showing you on the screen
right now is this what we have
identified with exhibit 78 yes sir
this was the second screenshot sent by
jennifer crumbley right and that was in
a text spread between jennifer crumbley
and james truman correct the facebook
message
and that means it was sent by jennifer
two james correct yes sir okay thank you
and i'm going to put up exhibit 7 right
now
and the services will be identified as
the first screenshot sent that correct
yes sir
going back now to 18
which is the text the facebook message
right between jennifer and james crumbly
what time were these screenshots sent
they were sent at 11 30 20 21 at 9 38
a.m
i scroll down and i see
a duplicate message which is there can
you tell what happened there it's just
where the software it searches multiple
areas and the device stores in different
places so whether it's under a file
system extraction or what's called a
logical assessment logical extraction
it's just letting you know that it found
in multiple places thank you
yeah identical thank you next
okay what was uh the response from james
crumbly to jennifer crumlin
james respond with my god wtf that's wtf
yeah
that was said november 30th 2021 9 44 am
from james jenner yes sir
what's his next post the next message
rather
that not here yet it's michael murray
and curious foreign
that was at 9 45am
and what was jennifer crumley's response
her response he said he was distraught
about last night
so she wrote he said he was distraught
about last night on november 30 2021 at
9 50 a.m
what was james premier's response go
ahead and continue
james then said you talked to him
and then her response she responded with
can you call
question mark penny to a school
okay
and then what is this last post here um
first post on page 2046
it's definitely saying i'm very
concerned
she wrote that november 30th 2021 at 10
04 am right
and then
at 10 12
she stated she said headed to a school
now these facebook messages here that
refer to
i think 9 33 a.m was the first one and
then 10
12 58 was the last one is that right
correct okay now through the data
extractions are you able to tell that
they're communicating
other than just facebook
yes sir okay you have a chance to review
the call logs yes sir
and are call logs part of your standard
data extractions information
yes sir
i'm going to
show you for people proposed
19.
so that is a pdf export from a call log
data extraction james chromosome is that
right
right so that's obviously not every
phone call for the history of device but
that's specific to that date that's been
supported all right correct yes there's
one highlighted portion on there and
what is the date time for that the big
time is 11 30 20 21 at 10 29 a.m does
that have a phone number
who he called it's to
the contact label jen
248-760-7502
and that's the phone number you later
learned to be jennifer friendly correct
yes sir okay and that's the export that
you received from james from his phone
yes sir people moved him at 19.
any objection
all right no objection no objection
detective on the screen here
we're looking at the same exhibit this
is exhibit 19.
yes sir okay
we'll highlight a portion this is two
and then the phone number you identified
jennifer crumbly with the date november
30 2021 in the time of 10 29 a.m yes sir
and does it have a length in the phone
conversation the length is seven minutes
to 16 seconds okay so we can tell they
have a phone conversation
at 10 23 am for seven minutes is that
right
10 29 10
10 20.
11 30 the time is 10 29 correct
yes ma'am
we have no objection to the admission of
this but the highlighting the prosecutor
has got to do it makes it look like they
only have one seven minute call when
there's multiple calls between jen and
james like preceding the highlighted
call i can see that i mean that's
clearly visible that there's more than
one call he's just asking him about the
one and highlighted so if you want to
ask him about the others you certainly
will have that opportunity
no problem
all right
now were you able to tell if anyone from
the oxford high school contacted
jennifer crumley in the morning in
november
and looking at this exhibit number 19.
no i'm sorry we're moving on now um
now in addition to the data extraction
that you perform on these devices you
can testify earlier that you
went to oxford high school and you
actually reviewed the footage in front
of you
were you requested to review footage
from
the meetings with james and jennifer
crumbling with members of the astronaut
high school on november 3rd yes sir
all right you've come to learn that
oxford high school has both internal and
external surveillance all right yes sir
now were you able to determine what time
these defendants arrived at the oxford
high school
on november the 30th of 2012
i believe it was about 10 30 7. okay now
sir when you went through this did you
make any notes about it yes it is okay
um
we say i believe if you're not sure let
me know let me know
may i approach
to keep the time straight am i right yes
sir okay so i'm referring specifically
to november the 30th 2021 the time that
james and jennifer crumbly arrived
it wasn't 1037.
and then do you have recollection of
when james and jennifer finally were
actually seen into the office
real quick they entered the office
at 10 39
25 seconds yeah do you know what time
they were greeted by a school employee
at 10 40.
and what time did they
were they escorted somewhere yes okay
and what time were they seeing next on
the cameras leaving me they were seen
leaving counseling at 10 53
so this meeting lasted according to your
camera review approximately 13 minutes
yes sir
what time did they leave the school
they left the school at 10 54.
did they arrive at the school in one car
or two cars one time did they leave a
one car
one car
what time do they actually leave the
actual school down
or read the parking lot at 10 50
so i'm going to show you on the screen
here it's already been admitted as
people sit
this is a series of screenshots of
messages between carapanic curacao and
jennifer crum
i'm sorry what exhibit are you looking
at
now sir told us that they left the
parking lot james and jennifer from the
left the parking lot together in
november the 30th 2021 at 10 56 a.m
correct i'm looking for the first
message
after
10 56 a.m what do we see here
it's a message at 10 58 a.m okay and
we've already identified this against
jennifer crumbly
okay i'll bring some out later just had
to go to my son's school and his
counselor shift it
now you've told us
that you've had the opportunity
to review messages on jennifer cronin's
phone all right correct okay did you see
this particular message on the jennifer
cromley's phone
i don't remember seeing that okay if it
wasn't on jennifer crumby's advice what
did that tell you
that it was deleted
sir you have the chance to look at it
told us about door dash search warrant
yes sir and you did
yes
this is people's twenty
sir what am i handing you right now
uh this uh this is a map i
made the
search warrant here okay and what did
you do with the information and how do
you create them
i just uh put marks on there for when
the first door dash pickup was and what
time it was the location on the map and
where that drop off was in relation to
the premier presidents
now what is the first we know this maybe
ended in 10 56
information first activity on james
charlie's door
after that meeting are you moving to
admit this yes sir thank you
any objection to the admissibility of
exhibit 20.
i know you're on earth on your honor get
admitted go ahead now you can ask me
thank you um sir what is the first
activity you see
so i want to make sure my times are
right the first
message from
jennifer crumpley was the cara pinnacle
1050
and the first activity and james from
his phone was 11 a.m which is four
minutes after the apartment all right
the first activity from the door dance
recorder
what is this door dash record that he
had his first pickup was at 1100 and
dropped it off at 11 19. so he was
making door gas to it yes sir
and doesn't have the last store
destroyed
there are a total of four of them on
there the fourth one was at 12 51
pick up and dropped off
all right i'm going to give you your
name
the situation he's going to contact you
okay once
[Music]
240.
[Music]
okay
[Music]
thank you
that was exhibit five which we have yeah
does your data extraction also include
internet search results yes
sir yes
1129 2021 at 305 a.m
and that was taken from jennifer
crumley's phone right yes right in the
data extraction yes sir people move to
admit 21.
any objection from jennifer probably no
your honor
james crumbly no your honor could be
admitted
okay i'm publishing on the screen here
sir we have a snippet like you said web
history of four
what is the search terms entered on
jennifer cronin's phone
research clinical depression treatment
options
and what time was that
that was at 11 29 2021 at 305 a.m
and then we have that repeated here
for this entire export present
which i was question why is it repeated
like this because actually what i went
and did i clicked on each one of those
it just took me to a different page you
know there's a page one patient page
three of the initial survey okay so what
did she actually take a
typed in research clinical depression
treatment
now going back to the 293 page text
thread between ethan crumbling and
jennifer primary specifically pages
you know about 150
[Music]
did you recognize those three pages
yes sir
how do you recognize that it's a chat
conversation between
ethan and jennifer okay what date does
that start
starts on the first date on here is
march 6
this is exhibit 20
any objection of the epidemic probably
no justin your honor the objection of
james comey no objection
i'm gonna direct you specifically to the
first text message
on march the 9th 2021 so we're looking
at the first page this would be page
150 of the 293 page text string
and it's uh from it appears to be from
ethan crumbly is that correct right
that's right
jennifer
and what's the first text here in the
time
he's saying can you get home now
on march 9th 2021 at 7 50 p.m okay
please continue
it follows up with there's someone in
the house i think
what time is that
7 50 p.m in 17 seconds
and he says someone walked into the
bathroom flushed the toilet and left the
light on
at 7 50 and 39 seconds yeah
and the next uh and i thought it was you
but when i came out there was no one
home
uh there's no one in the house though th
oh
dude my door just slammed
and what does he write in march march 9
2021 801
maybe it's just my
maybe it's just my paranoia
in the next message well
ethan says but when are you going to get
home
is there a response
at some point
not on that day
what's the first response
first response the next day
at 10 21 a.m where's your dad
it's the last text
from ethan about maybe it's just my
paranoia and then but when are you going
to get home with her at 801 pm march
tonight practice the first response from
jennifer crumbly is march the 10th at 10
21 am right yes sir
i'm going to show you
pages 171 to 173 that same thread this
is exhibit 23.
they approach
yes
and sir do you recognize what i've
handed you
yes sir and again that is the same
text thread of ethan and jennifer
crumbling right yesterday
people moved to admits 23. the objection
jennifer cumberland
pages 171 to 173 that same thread this
is exhibit 23.
and sir do you recognize what i've
handed you
yes sir and again that is the same
text thread
of ethan and jennifer crumbly correct
yes sir okay
people move to mid-23
[Music]
okay i'm gonna publish on the screen let
me know if you can't read it okay
detective
now
starting with
this blue bubble on the left mark 17 20
21 603 p.m that's from ethan crumbly to
jennifer crumley am i right correct yes
sir okay what does that say
says okay the host the house is now
haunted
okay what's next
he then says some weird shit just
happens and now i'm scared
i got some videos what time is that that
was at 603 and 12 seconds p.m
tell me what's this this text right here
saying
on the next page i'm sorry yes
the next uh text says and a picture of
the demon okay and what time and date
does he send the text and a picture of
the demon
that was at 603 and 12 seconds pm mark
17 2021 part 17 yes sir okay the next
text
he texts it is throwing bowls in all
capital letters
also 603 pm yes sir okay the next test
next text says
i'm not joking
it fucked up the kitchen
at 6 03 pm okay the next one
he says i'm not i'm just going to be an
outsider for a while be outsider for a
while
and that's 603 as well
yes sir
and what about on march 17 6 29 p.m was
he right 6 29 he says can you at least
text back
is there a response from jennifer
crumble there not on that date sir
so i want to make sure that we're all
clear these text messages here this was
found on the text message thread between
jennifer and james crumbly these weren't
selectively exported this is the way the
text message conversation read am i
right
jennifer and ethan jennifer and ethan
thank you yes sir this is the way that
the conversation actually read yes sir
okay
so the first response from jennifer
crumbly to ethan crumbly on text message
was this one right here on march 19 2021
at 4 11 pm when she writes where is your
dad correct yes sir okay
now if we could let's continue
the next text message
march 19 2021
at 7 48 i'm sorry yes the next one uh 7
48 p.m text me when you're done okay
then at 9 02 pm she texts done yet
question mark
in the next test text message on the
spread from ethan to jennifer crumbly as
it occurs what time
it occurred
the next on march 20th 2021 at 2 33 pm
and what is he right i finished picking
up the room
okay the next text please
i cleaned until the clothes started
flying off the shelf what time did you
write that that was on march 20th at 2
34 p.m okay in the following text
following text this stuff only happens
when i'm home alone
what time is that at 2 34 p.m
all right and then the last tax on this
right here
i picked the close back up though at 2
34 p.m
now
because you've actually reviewed all
three data extractions in all social
media accounts
when you learn something along the lines
of this information such as on march
17th 2021 ethan crumbly texting
took a picture of the demon were able to
then go back through these defendant
cell phones to get an idea of what
they're doing in those dates yes sir and
did you do that in this case yes sir
are you able through your data
extractions to tell us
what jennifer crumbly was doing
on march the 9th march 17th and march
the 20th
uh horseback riding all right
now how were you able to make that
determination the you could go and look
at the pictures and just narrow down
your search for those specific days or
the software puts everything in a
timeline so it's just a chronological
order of when things are happening on
that device
and do images stored on
jennifer crumley's phone on that device
do they have a date and time stamp yes
sir
may i approach it with this yes
this is people supposed
24.
that's a photograph yes sir and do you
recognize that photograph yes sir how do
you recognize it i've seen it on
jennifer's phone okay does it have a
date and time stamp at the bottom yes
sir okay and what is the date and time
uh march 9th 2021 at 4 55 p.m
okay people move to mid-24
no objection
okay what we're looking at here on the
screen is the photograph taken from
jennifer krum whose phone and we have it
taken on march 9th 2021 at 4 55 game is
that right correct yes sir okay
man approach
yes sir and does that photograph have a
date and time stamp it does march 17th
2021 at 6 03 p.m okay people move to
mid-25
[Music]
this is a photograph of james crumbley's
sort on jennifer crumby's phone am i
right correct yes sir okay and the date
and time is march 17th 2012 2021 at 603
pm yes sir and what was happening at
march 17th 2021 at 603 pm on that text
message thread ethan was texting his mom
i believe on the march 17th when he was
that's what he was seeing
he said the house the house is haunted
and he has videos
and a picture of the demon
this is a photograph people post 26.
sir do you recognize that program yes
sir also uh it's seen on jennifer's
phone people move to mit 26
[Music]
and we also have a date and time stamp
on the bottom of this correct yes sir
okay you would characterize this as a
selfie am i right yes sir all right this
is march 17th 2021 at 603 pm yes sir
and
finally
yes sir how do you recognize that again
it was on jennifer's phone people moved
to admit 27
thank you and this was taken march 20
2021 at 12 02 p.m am i right correct yes
sir all right again photographs of
horses
yes sir
now looking at
the data extraction on jennifer
crumley's phone
we can see no text back in relation to
clothes flying off the shelves or seeing
demons things like that but were there
any other phone calls or any other
messages any other messaging apps no sir
now were there any text messages
in relation to
demons or things flying off shelves or
the house being haunted and james
crumley's phone to ethan crondo no sir
with any phone calls from james crumly
to ethan crumbly during this time span
no sir no phone calls from jennifer
crumley to ethan crumby during this time
span either no sir
this is back to the facebook messenger
thread between
jennifer crumbly and james crumbly this
is a portion of pages four four zero to
four forty three
and this is that over two thousand page
facebook messenger yes sir just make
sure we're on the same page
may i approach witness yes
so you recognize what i've just handed
you
yes sir okay and how do you recognize
that
it was a
a conversation with uh james and
jennifer through facebook messenger
facebook messenger but we already have a
stipulation of this this is exhibit 28.
that's 28. yes sir
yes
okay i'm going to publish it on the left
now this is the conversation between
james and jennifer carmel and the same
dates that we were just referring to
when ethan crumbly was texting jennifer
crumbly about seeing a demon the house
is haunted for context okay yes sir yep
so on the left we have
from jc rumbly you identified that as
jennifer crumley's account correct on
the right we have james r crumbly which
we've identified as james chrome's
account correct all right
so i'm going to go to
all right starting with
march 19 2021 9 37 a.m from jennifer to
james what did she write
9 37 uh you awake okay and then the next
message please ethan awake james's
response
james responds um yeah
okay and jennifer she responds with how
is how is he okay what is james right
he responds with he woke up looking like
he had whey in all caps too much to
drink last night complaining about a
headache okay what was jennifer's
response to that
she responded with well
he was really worked up and out of
control so i can see why
okay the next message
all i know is he needs to eat go to work
and work hard and not complain and he
can get his stuff back okay the next
message
uh jennifer's asking you respond and i
didn't get it question mark and then
these responses
uh james responds with jesus
yes
okay then when did you write to her
march 19 20 21 at 10 17 a.m
he said
let me ask you a question
why am i
in your guy's room lol okay just so
we're clear the text actually says he
said
not you're not actually saying what
james said am i right correct yes okay
correct
and then her response
omg and what's that mean for the record
general oh my god
um what does james write to jennifer on
march 19th at 10 17am
i totally thought you were giving him a
xanax last night
her response does he seem better
no melatonin okay what does james say i
know
okay please continue with it okay
but
jennifer then says
but he hasn't had one before should only
give it should only give him half james
responds with
he is just doing his school says his
head hurts he took so tylenol
jennifer responds with is he okay to
work question mark
james says yeah
jennifer says does he remember what he
did
james says
dude i am working on a demo right now i
have not talked to him and he is doing
school
okay
and those were facebook conversations
between james and jennifer crumbly am i
right correct yes sir okay
now
back to
exhibit 10.
that is the text thread
between
the end of the text wrap between ethan
crumbly and jennifer
i'm going to pull that up again for you
it's already been admitted
i just want you to tell us please
what is the last thing
that jennifer crumbly writes to ethan
crumbly on this text
do i still have this i can't see that
screen that far
i still have that one
press these two pages
at what time
the very last text message
the very last section was ethan don't do
it okay that was the last text message
from jennifer crumbley to ethan crumbly
that was november the 30th 30th 2021 at
1 22 p.m is that right correct yes sir
now sir we were talking about jennifer
from this phone i want to talk to you a
little bit about what was found on ethan
crumley's phone
now did you uncover a text message
thread between ethan crumbly and
another individual we're not going to
name but we know that that person is a
juvenile
did you uncover a text message between
ethan crumbly and that person yes sir
okay
and how long was that text from there's
about 25 000
chats text back and forth i'm comparing
that text message thread on ethan
premier's phone to all other message
threads
is there anything that's
is remotely close in size or
sorry
anything remotely close in size to the
level of text messages between ethan
crumbly and that juvenile no the next
closest was just over a hundred okay so
it's fair to say based upon your data
extraction of ethan crumley's phone that
is the person he communicated with the
most correct yes sir okay
now i want to specifically point you to
the dates of april the 5th
2021 on that text message thread
and this is exhibit
29. approach
yes
judge so you're aware we had a
discussion council and i had a
discussion earlier today about certain
portions being redacted or not redacted
we have
complied with council's requests and
provided unredacted portions
is that correct
you have these unreacted portions after
the conversation yes
which are separate from what you've
given to the coordinates yes so may i
approach
so this will be the new exhibit 29.
with those
modifications i don't believe we have an
objection to the admissibility of
exhibit 29
um but let me ask you detective
this was a portion of the text message
thread between ethan crumley and that
juvenile correct yes sir okay and on the
top of page 29
um what's what's the date and time
april 5th 2021 at 12 38 a.m okay and we
already know this is from ethan
crumley's device from his phone right
correct yes sir so on the right it's
going to be green it's going to say
owner
correct that would be ethan crumbling
yes sir and it's going to say 2 is going
to be the person he's texted too great
yes sir right okay
people move to admit 29
no doctrine no objection for mr
can i vote for a moment
ah
thank you judge i appreciate that
okay again referring to exhibit 29
the green bean ethan crumbly's phone
what's the first message with the date
and time date and time is april 5th 2021
at 12 38 a.m
says i'm going to ask my parents to go
to the doctors tomorrow or tuesday again
the next test the next one is the same
date
just a few seconds later at 12 38 and 15
seconds am but this time i'm going to
tell them about the voices
we have one moment runner
okay the third text message here
third message is i only told him about
the people i saw okay what time was that
that was uh at 12 38 a.m 25 seconds
in the response in the blue bubble
the response was okay
now i want to talk to you about this one
right here on page three
april 5th 2021 at 12 39 a.m
what is that text message from ethan
from ethan says
like i am mentally and physically dying
and that is on april the 5th of 2021 am
i correct great kisser all right
now on this
large substantial text thread between
ethan crumley and that other individual
there were videos as attachments as well
yes sir okay you have the opportunity to
review not only the text messages but
those images yes sir okay
now was there a video sent on august the
19th 2021 from ethan crumbly to this
person yes sir right
and you've had the opportunity to view
that from the data extraction on ethan
crumbly's phone correct yes sir
people move to mitt 30.
here and i can unhook it
sure
you're looking on the flash drive are
you going to show it to her now before
you move to events
thank you
all right
is in recess
oh that's okay i need to stand up a
little bit yeah
get the blood flowing yeah
oh
i'm coming right behind you
so
so
[Music]
ah
um
and that's
thank you
see she's in the hallway
yes
so
this is
yes
yes
it was just
background
few
[Music]
[Music]
okay
yes
so
all rise for the new session
okay um please be seated we did contact
the county and um they are going to
adjust the temperature remotely for us
so it should be okay and we do need to
close those outer doors
videos
so now we're going to be in the dark
[Music]
it's another facility station
i don't know
[Music]
is it just did that just happen yes
right
yes we talking about the light yeah no
about this the picture oh he was up
there already
right but that just happened where it
was dead like that
yes
that doesn't really help you much
did it happen after you hooked back up
no this is just the way it's just our
video okay go ahead and try it and if
it's an issue then we have to get it
to the court in the flash drive as well
if she's a corporate viewer
i don't know if i can do it on this one
all right let's go ahead and try and if
not then
that's fine i can see him
between ethan and crumbling the other
juvenile at 25 000 or so text thread
there were videos included that you
viewed yes sir okay specifically on
august the 19th of 2021 did you view a
video on that text message thread yes
sir and that was a video sent from ethan
crumbley to that other person yes sir
okay
people didn't move to him
any objection no judge no judgment
okay by the referee's attention please
to the screen to make sure we're
referring to it
yes sir this is august the 19th of 2021
and it appears to have a person holding
a handgun is that correct correct yes
sir okay nobody's ever heard of the end
what was that they uh the person hit the
slide lock release so the slide went
forward
that's exhibit 30.
did you also review a video in the same
text throughout the same conversation
shortly after that one was sent in the
early morning hours of august the 20th
yes sir
this
is 31.
that's
this is correct 11 second clip
again this was sent from ethan crumley
to that other individual that correct
correct yes sir
now sir
i'm going to back this up just a little
bit
you're 25 years as a police officer
you've obviously handled firearms
yes sir okay and you've seen
the ammunition for firearms yes sir okay
you know how to properly load a handgun
yes sir okay tell me what's happening in
this video
he inserted the magazine
into the magazine well and you can see
the top of one of the bullets
yes sir okay does that mean there's a
round in the chamber there
as soon as that slide goes forward there
will be okay
and prior to this point of the video
this is at
the very beginning of the video what is
this object right here that's uh appears
to be vertical
on the
counter cup that's a handgun magazine
okay and what's in the handgun magazine
those are bullets
we play that again so we can see it
that was 31. sir were there was there a
text message conversation in the midst
of these videos being sent yes sir okay
so this is people's 32 and in like
people's 29 we made some changes to the
redaction so this would be a new copy
for the court the defense has this as
well
yeah
yes this is people's proposed 32
and sir once you take a look at it could
you please tell me if this is in the
same text thread that we had admitted uh
people's 29 which is the text message
throughout between ethan crumbly and
that other juvenile yes sir
and what is the date and time of the
first text message on that piece of
paper there the first message is a video
8 19 20 21
at 9 31 p.m okay and that's the video
that we watched in people's 30 yes sir
okay people move to emit exhibit 32
okay thank you
green is um the owner again is that
correct yes sir okay and it has the
phone number where it's sent to and he
said this attachment the video was sent
august 19th 2021 at 9 31 pm correct okay
i'm sorry i have the same one
one moment please
there we go okay
okay then we have a response to that
video being sent what is that response
the response from the other juvenile is
nice okay and there's
spelled
correctly or no there's a couple extra
eyes
n-i-i-i-c-e okay
and then what was the message from ethan
crumley
ethan then says shoot that sunday
question mark and that's august the 19th
2021 at 9 30 4 p.m correct yes sir
okay the next text
even says if you don't want to come to
the range to the gun range that's fine
you can just tell me no hard feelings
okay any response to that
the other juvenile states nah
i do but it's just kind of hard for me
to ask
rn what's rna
right now okay
any response
um okay and that was sent in august 19th
2021 and 1106 p.m correct okay
uh response
next next text please from the other
juvenile was sorry okay
and then what did ethan crumbly write
it's okay
and the following text is an attachment
is that right correct yes sir that
attachment is a video correct yes sir
and um am i correct it's august the 20th
2021 at 12 30 a.m correct yes sir okay
and that's the video that we saw in
exhibit 31 yes sir okay
and then the other person's
response
nice again misspelled with three eyes
okay and please continue reading
the other juve then states now pull the
trigger
jk jk jk jk
and then there's it doesn't appear to be
any response in this text bubble from
ethan crumbly to that person is that
right correct all right the next text
please
my dad left it out so i thought quote
why not lol and what time do you write
my dad left it off out so i thought why
not
it's at 12 32 a.m on the morning of the
20th august 20th
okay
and there's no response here correct
correct
all right and then what did ethan
currently write
he responds with
i cave i know
gun safety so it's no problem
please continue
ethennes says now it's time to shoot up
the school
in the final text in this export
jkjkjkjkjk
okay that was sent from ethan crumley to
this other individual august the 20th
2021 at 12 34am is that right correct
yes
now
you reviewed this entire text message
thread between ethan crumley and that
individual is that right correct yes sir
and we have talked about the number of
text messages that printed out the over
i think you said 25 000 pages is that
right yes sir was there a time when this
text message history just abruptly
stopped yes sir and when was that
it was
middle around october
around halloween time i believe is when
it was
of 2021 yes sir i'm sorry okay
now sir
during the review of the data extraction
on ethan crumbly's phone what else did
you observe know
there were tax messages back and forth
between the other juvenile and him of um
kidnapping and killing another classmate
there's also videos of killing um and
mutilating baby birds
okay anything else
um
not that i can recall well sir are you
able to look at his web history yes sir
okay now i don't want to name the
website but was there a particular
um
on his web searching history are you
able to identify a particular website
that he identified that he visited quite
often yes sir okay and just to give us
an idea how many times did he
visit that particular site in the month
of november of 2021 421 times
and what were sort of some of the sort
of things that he was searching it was
very graphic content it dealt with other
school shootings particularly ones in
florida um and people being killed okay
now we've talked a lot about
you know this was ethan crumley's phone
jennifer crumbly's phones james truman's
phone et cetera
were you able to determine who actually
owned ethan crumby's phone yes sir and
who was that james crumbly was the owner
on all the accounts okay and he paid the
bills yes sir thank you one moment
detective during the course of during
the course of your investigation did you
come to learn that there was more than
one gun in the crumbling home yes sir
okay so we've been referring to the nine
millimeter sig that was the firearm used
in the actual shooting am i right
correct yes sir okay what were the other
firearms found in the crumbling house
there was a caltech i believe
i believe it was
a 22 caliber and then there was a small
derringer okay now the videos that we
saw in people's 30 and 31 that what kind
of gun is that if you can tell
that was the caltech 22 caltech yes sir
and that's also semi-automatic yes sir
thank you
um
your honor can i stay at the table and
the question from here yes just keep
your voice up okay
um good afternoon good afternoon
i want to go back to
exhibit 29
then really what i need to do is have
you help me understand
the reports
when you take stuff off of a celebrate
report
it's fair to say there's different ways
you can extract the information is that
correct
well
to be precise
take information off the the data
from the phone and then export reports
from that data yes okay and when you
testify that if if messages are deleted
um sometimes those will not come up in
the report is that correct they won't
come up in the extraction the
analyzation of the data yes ma'am okay
so your honor um
can i approach the witness with
um
may i approach the witness with these
materials
it's like materials
um these are the texts between ethan and
the other young man that we've been
discussing
okay on the record
they're not they're not they're not
exhibits at this point
okay so you just need to make sure
they're identified correctly that's all
okay
so
this is all one
this is all there's two separate files
but i'm gonna ask you about that
okay so detective i just handed you a
very large stack of papers
and um
if you take a quick skin through it it
appears to be the all of the messages
between ethan crumbly
and his friend
um who were not identifying on the
record name starts with b
does that does that appear true to you
that looks great yes ma'am okay so at my
office when i get your celebrate report
um i pulled up all of these messages
printed them and brought them into court
today and if every page is there you
would agree with me that that's from the
celebrate report is that a fair
statement
it came from it's a celebrate report yes
ma'am i can tell you that because the
logo is on there it looks like it should
i don't know if it were you're asking is
it every message that they share back
and forth well no i there'd be no way to
verify that because there's so many
thousands um i'm just asking
if i'm telling you that i printed those
off celebrate does that
does that look like what you would
expect to look like yes ma'am it does
okay so i want to turn your attention to
exhibit 29 which was admitted when the
prosecution was um
questioning you your honor may i
approach the witness
i have exhibit 29 29 yes
okay and exhibit 29 contains a series of
text messages
that were from april 4 2021.
yes ma'am
okay and those messages specifically um
that were admitted in exhibit 29
those messages
did not print when i printed the
messages so
i'm wondering if you can explain why
the printouts i printed from celebrate
would be missing those some of those
messages without having where you
printed that from and be able to examine
myself there's no way i can tell you
that
okay is it possible that those messages
were deleted by the user of the phone
no if it was in there if it was in the
original data that was given to you it
doesn't matter if it was deleted it
would still show it would still be there
there is not
as far as you know there is not a way
to filter out
um
dates if you print the entire thing as a
whole correct
printing the entire thing as a whole
from the first text to the last if
that's what this is then that's what
should be there yes
and
can you
take a look at the texts i printed from
4
5 of 21
and can you show me where
the texts on exhibit 29 fall into that
where they where they would be
i think we're going to have to i'm going
to have to object here because
detective obamacare has testified to the
exhibits that we've admitted because he
actually exported them using the
celebrate software this was just handed
to him five minutes ago
i didn't print out point five thousand
text messages because i'm not going to
knit 25 000 text messages there's just
no way for this officer to know that
that is in fact the entire text threat
between ethan crumbling and the other
person but she certainly can ask him
about his particular date and if it
doesn't jump it doesn't match up in what
smith has handed it but we just don't
know
we have an expert in cell phone
forensics because it takes some skill to
actually extract some of this ability
and take some expertise which he has so
we just don't know it could quite
frankly just be user error we don't know
if that is actually representative text
thread the entire text right there's no
way to know from a paper in your honor
in all honesty um
accuracy and getting things right is
what's important in this case making
sure that it's accurate
i don't understand why all of the texts
are missing many texts that the
prosecution is using
i'm trying to understand that but to be
quite frank i asked this court to
adjourn so that we can explore this
issue and figure this out this is a very
big deal that we are we do not have
these texts just for clarification are
you asking him
to identify whether or not
the exhibit is the entire string of the
text thread
i can't have him because he didn't print
that out i all i can say is i printed it
out as the entire screen
i can ask does it appear to be the
entire set of text messages
so you are
are you asking him to identify where
exhibit 29 page one calls in yes where
those exhibits are yes and they're in
order by date
so
detective if you could go to april 5th
uh yeah if i could just
um i mean there ain't chronological
order yeah
there there's one thing that i just
stand i don't know again
um if these are the the messages the
file path the source info that this came
from that this right here is different
than the source info here they should be
the same i don't know why that is
but i'll look for the the text messages
where they should be in here
from just look it should be this is the
first one that i see for april 5th
in this stack
and the next one
i'm sorry stan let me just apologize
it shows
april 5th there 3 54 a.m and then
3 17.
so
somewhere with in between
these two dates these two messages right
here
so so i mean just for clarification for
my own purposes when i'm looking at
exhibit number 29 for the database
anywhere from 12 38
am through
12 39 a.m
are you able to identify those bubbles
in the standard materials
no ma'am no no ma'am
okay your honor um i know this court
heard our motion to adjourn earlier
today council
co-counsel and i have been dealing with
thousands and thousands of pages
we are very clearly missing
pages that are being admitted as
evidence in this case i ask the court to
adjourn and give us an opportunity
to look into this issue this is a very
big deal
if they're admitting a few pages
and we don't have those in what's the
entire printout that
and that's happened with a couple of
sections of it that's a big problem for
the defense so they're not missing
anything
this detective took the same program the
same evidence that we had as the
prosecutor's office we turned over to
defense
she just didn't find it in the evidence
that's been given to her and this
detective can testify to that what he
did exactly to export this he just
testified that the final path is
different the source file if you export
and i don't want to testify myself
that's why we have an expert oh that's
why you have the expert that just
exhibit number 29.
how did you
obtain how did you go through to obtain
the
information that's on exhibit 29
within the whole
the whole
chat thread text thread you would
uncheck every call every
message going back and forth and just
check the ones you want and then just
export as a pdf
so it's your testimony that you
you went from
all of the text messages
and i picked out the ones you want to
check those off and printed those out is
that correct separate reports yes ma'am
and so if my office printed out all the
messages and we printed them out
correctly those messages should be in my
complete stack if printed correctly yes
ma'am your honor i am asking the court
to adjourn they are printed correctly
and we are missing messages
and if if this is user error or an issue
this is something that needs to be
determined
[Music]
cheers
um
so
ready
so
um
more
so
so
okay
um
all right back down the record and uh
people versus crumbling the court hit
some uh discussions with councilman that
um due to the voluminous nature of the
exhibits of the victim we are not likely
to finish with this witness today we're
going to go ahead and
continue the exam
on february 24th
starting at 8 30
um a.m necessary for the court to add an
additional day after the 24th after the
24th we'll revisit that issue on that
date and time
however um i am indicating to all
parties that i have cleared that day
specifically for this case so you will
have the full day
as far as exhibits go
prosecutors
take all original exhibits with you
everybody has their copies
and your
council identified two witnesses we
asked about if one of those witnesses is
not going to be called we just ask them
to give us a notice so we can subpoena
that witness to here
sure
thank you the prosecution said they get
back to us no problem so thank you okay
thank you
um
thank you
okay
so
[Music]
thank you
oh